hey ball hog hey buddy dude you know I
had today
mmm duck eggs duck egg you don't need
them now
you don't need them in your life no good
is the reason why they sell chicken eggs
in that decade B Oh duck eggs where did
you get duck it bear one oh yeah I go to
air one yeah like Oh duck eggs and
tastes notably shitty ah really yeah
like gooey like it sticks the roof of
your mouth is it smaller - no there's
bigger there big duck sir
maybe quail eggs I've had yeah those are
good those are good and they're small
yeah they're really little cuz quail are
tiny but ducks are big [ __ ] yeah they
are they [ __ ] out some big eggs and
they're nasty really they like stick to
your mouth like do you fry it
mm-hmm same way like same way loose yolk
or no like easy yeah it's like regular
yolk but the yolk sticks to your mouth
all right stays inside your mouth it
sounds like a ball hog
yeah it's not I don't recommend I'm
feeding the rest of them to my dog I
think really he loves them loves eggs
he loves eggs Marshall is yeah I crack
open an egg and mix it in with his
kibble sometimes that's awesome
yeah most the time I feed him either he
gets a little bit of kibble and some elk
meat
I give him ground elk meat or some other
kind of meat much to spoil he's well
he's well that's awesome - he's a happy
dog yeah I think everyone loves Marshall
madam yeah metal you met him here right
couple times yeah he's a sweetest dog in
the world
yeah the door like I didn't even know
the dogs were like that yeah it's a
special dog it's golden retrievers man
they're smart - they're real smart I
have a [ __ ] box of sand as a dog but
she's adorable she's sweet but she's
dumping [ __ ]
what is she Brussels Griffon I don't
know what that is look like an Ewok oh
okay
yeah that's right yeah that's an odd
choice is that your wife's choice of
course yeah yeah fraud's
the edge you get you at the dog choice
wheat little dog but they basically want
a baby that they don't care too much of
it dies pretty sad I'm not like
babysitting now [ __ ]
it's like a it's like a baby that you
know you only have to take care of for
like 14 years yeah yeah we talk about it
sometimes like I love you so much I'll
say it to the dog and I know you won't
be here long
you know ya know she's pretty young
though so I think I think we know for
lucky she'll have a good run I lost the
dog last year that was terrible yeah
I've lost the dog two years ago it's
rough it's two dogs in a row well they
both were so old they couldn't walk
anymore and archived horrible hard
condition and you know we've given him
all the meds and he was just on a
decline and I was on the road when he
died it was you know I just was kind of
stunned and I and I kind of you know I
had to keep doing the shows obviously
right it was like a long weekend the
shows then when I got back I [ __ ]
broke down mm-hmm yeah it really [ __ ]
you up
it's a weird relationship humans and
animals you know yeah yeah it's and yeah
especially like if you you grow up with
dogs yeah yeah so it's like it really
becomes like it feels weird when you
don't have a dog or me I've always had a
dog yeah I've always had cats and dogs
always most of my life yeah either like
when I was living in apartment in New
York I had a cat and bossed I had a cat
and then when I soon as I got to LA I
got dogs yeah soon as I go to the yard
I'm like it's the best like the first
thing I thought of they're the best
no they have they bark when someone's
coming near your [ __ ] house it's true
yeah really and they have that extra
system in them you know that that level
of sensitivity to sound and smell that
like yeah when they start what are you
talking about yeah they see things like
when I was having coyote problems
I took Marshall out even when he was
pretty young he was like six seven
months old I took a mountain and I'm
like well you what are you freaking out
about and then I turned look and I see
these eyeballs moving through the trees
outside the chicken coop I'm like you
little [ __ ] it's [ __ ] coyote [ __ ]
coyotes are such [ __ ] banned there's
such [ __ ] so I lived in you know in
this neighborhood where walk pull out of
your driveway noon
yeah standing in the middle of street oh
yeah looking around you well Whitney
lives in Woodland Hills yeah yeah is
that Street for me bro her areas
infested she
he's got dogs like three or four dogs in
the yard barking and these cows don't
give a [ __ ] did you see that video where
the pack came into her house or into her
yard yeah it was like six of them yeah
yeah that neighbor that neighborhood
they're sketchy
I told her to get a subsonic 22 and you
start taking them out she won't put them
down pop pop put a little bait out there
mm-hmm does this city rules about taking
out of Keio the city rules you keep your
[ __ ] mouth shut
yeah shoot shovel and shut up is there
any upside they handle anything
yes rats rats yeah oh yeah man they're
great wood rats our vowels and ours are
way cooler than coyotes hmm and they
don't eat your larger dog you leave the
[ __ ] out your cat though they sure will
owls weed everything I said it's not an
owl flying with a rabbit a big-ass
rabbit in its claws once they're so
vicious yeah and there's such scary
hunters like I know at night and head
spins around have you ever seen that
video there's a nest video of these
Hawks that are in a tree and this owl
comes out and snatches one of the Hawks
and flies away and you just from a
distance they're like what is that right
when you you're talking about the one
with the eyeballs yeah and then also
like what and it goes BAM that's just
gone yeah yeah they're [ __ ] monsters
freaky animals man and we we think of
them as being these wise like like it's
professors of the woods for some strange
reason have you ever heard Matt Braunger
zal bit no it is one of the funniest
things is it really yeah this is like
the bit that he first liked his early on
you know getting his is a first big joke
that broke and um you know it was on
Letterman and he was on Comedy Central
it is a hug layer I got to see it I got
to see it as owls are one of those weird
animals that we have this very strange
relationship with well we don't know
what they really are yeah this distort
bears or another one we have this
distorted perception what did you see
that video that was going around about
that guy who got his face literally
eaten off by a grizzly and then he shot
the Grizzly when it was on top of him No
oh dude have you seen it Jamie yeah he's
talking he's like going around good yeah
yeah he's talking while his face is gone
and he's talking about like you could
see one eye through this mass I mean if
Jamie shakes his head like let me show
it to you real quick
yeah of his face to know it's right
after the attack the guard that was with
him started filming it and it's just one
of those things where okay so this is
the bear and this is the guy
and that's his face and this is him
talking where are you where are you
seeing this yes bro the thing shoots
face off that's him nasty looks like now
[ __ ] they rebuilt his face that's
incredible
did you have a doctor well you saw the
chimp victim lady yeah her face is gone
well that chimp worked on her for a
while did you see the tree trimming it
go go lower there Jamie go lower yeah
scroll down whoa what tree trimming what
what you've never seen that we're
talking about dude and there's and you
get to see the live oh where the tree
goes into the guy's face
this whole [ __ ] yeah it wide open yes
and then they show him in the hospital
yeah you can see even in his completely
destroyed face the panic and it's like
he knows how serious his situation is
yeah I mean they were able don't know I
haven't seen the post-surgery stuff but
that dude a tree just like perfect he
cut he was trimming and like he just cut
it and it didn't certainly swim right in
the face and split his whole [ __ ]
face yeah oh my god yeah
it's rough man yeah that's a rough look
right there that's a rough look it's
amazing how well they put that guy back
together if I was him I would just be
the Punisher for grizzly bears
I just just load up every year with a
million rounds of ammo
oh my just go hunting bears [ __ ] you
have you hunted a bear
you know yeah black bears not not crazy
bears yeah yeah we don't we have this
image of them because of teddy bears
because kids have them you know they
love them little teddy bears are the
biggest right yeah polar bears brown
bears and then yeah yeah yeah cuz I mean
a brown bear can stand up and be wet
like 9 feet taller bigger 11 really yeah
Kodiak the really big one hey Cody are
in a swipe capitated
my friend watched a bear kill a moose
with one SWAT broke its back
he watched it chased this moose through
a scope was looking at through a
spotting scope which is like like a
super powerful telescope yeah you could
look at you know like at my mile away
you can watch things happen and this
bear just SWAT hit this moose in the
back and snapped its back you have to
snap a mooses back oh my god I just tore
it apart
I mean how powerful is that animal it's
a big [ __ ] animal man you know you're
talking about a 1500 pound just ball a
muscle and fat I just thought about
sometimes like you know cuz you you know
a lot of obviously like trained fighters
and that that equation always plays in
your head what if like trained fighters
people don't realize sometimes how well
like how much that training puts that
person at an incredible advantage in a
fight right I sure like your average guy
right trying to get that smoke with a
trained fighter is a problem right but
at a certain point what's the equation
where all the training doesn't matter
your size yeah size and strength like
how big of a giant and how much how
powerful does he have to be where all
your training wouldn't matter it depends
on what kind of training you do like
with jiu-jitsu it's a pretty big
advantage right would you JIT say you
I've tapped guys that are a hundred
pounds heavier than me right just crazy
that is crazy yeah but I would never
strike with the guy that's 100 pounds
heavier than me cuz that would just yeah
you'd get killed
yeah cuz even through your gloves you
keep your gloves up and
300-pound guy just loves you with the
right hand yeah just like your whole
brain gets rattled right you can tap a
300-pound guy though as long as he
doesn't throw you on the ground the
problem is it picks you up in the air
and throws you on the ground slams you
and hit you with the earth yeah because
there are those like those dudes that
are almost animals you know you're
something walking around six eight oh
yeah 350 you know you're like you're
like I don't care how well you're
trained if that dude is like athletic oh
yeah like a pro gorilla pro football
player oh yeah like you see when I was I
remember I'll never forget this we were
in Phoenix and we were going into this
bar and it was like 20 plus years ago
and as we were waiting in line this pro
football player walked through the line
and it was like a grown-ass man amongst
little kids yeah it was like a third
grade class and someone's daddy showed
up and just walked through the line this
guy had to be like six seven six eight
350 he was so big I was laughing yeah I
was like look at the size of this
[ __ ] guy yeah just big old corn-fed
whiteboy just walking through the crowd
like Achin that dude gets ahold that's
what they do that's their job bro you
into the ground and just break
everything break your hip and your legs
and everything you know you don't follow
football but I always think of this dude
about like savagery Larry Allen he
played for the Kevin where the Cowboys
were dominant in the 90s this dude was
not just so big and so freaky strong but
like was born mean like he's what you
want if you're like again like he had
the athleticism the strength that's him
right there that Mindy 3 yes she's size
of this [ __ ] guy dude would just he
would just absolutely you know destroy
like break people's will how long did he
play for
oh he had played over 10 seasons and he
was he was like it's so big and so fast
so athletic this guy was so athletic man
like he was he there's amazing footage
of him just chasing like the his team
through interception he's chasing the
though the 180 pound guy down like crazy
[ __ ] bench 225 45 times you know just
imagine doing 45 push-ups yeah that's a
lot dude do 45 reps of the bar and
you're gonna feel the burn man yeah you
know like that's that's crazy
my my prop it's just it's it's nuts you
know he found benchpress here he's not a
normal 700 pound bench press god damn
not a normal the size of that dude
yeah these dudes are like yeah well you
know I mean yeah I think if that's your
gig your gigs to be gigantic and fast
and powerful and you've been working on
that since grade school
yeah look at them all [ __ ] around
jump they're jumping I'm lucky as an
animal like trained lion goddamn dude
yeah yeah he's so strong I ain't yeah
there's just like that mountain guy that
Game of Thrones guy like yeah get the
[ __ ] out exactly that's what I'm
thinking about it like guys like that
who are so if you're like oh but like I
see spar with Connor no car [ __ ] him
up oh he did yeah he [ __ ] him up like
really [ __ ] him up he just kept
hitting him he kept moving away from him
and then he couldn't hit Connor he's
trying to hit Connor he couldn't hit him
and Connor kept buh he was kicking him
in the stomach punch him in his stomach
that eventually just got exhausted and
he gave up you had to see that like that
part I mean in C but that's like kind of
like with rules right we're gonna do
mm-hmm
we're gonna do we couldn't grab he cried
to try to grab him yeah a goner there's
Jim so there's plenty of room for Connor
to move around him look at it but look
at the size difference between the two
of them see he started talking [ __ ] and
and Connor was like oh really
okay come on buddy let's spar let's spar
he doesn't know what to do right the
thing is Connor is much smaller than him
but here's know what to do see he just
hit Khan in the stomach there and he's
just know what to do yeah look at that
jump in front kick to the body and then
pushed him away he's trying to grab him
but he doesn't know what to do and
Carter just keeps moving and Connors in
great shape and that big [ __ ] has never
done cardio in his life all that guy
does do squats and deadlifts
just gets huge yeah so his his heart is
probably right now pounding out of his
chest that [ __ ] played basketball
before was oh he was really skinny yeah
he was really raising let's see now now
Connor starting to punch him he's
starting to punch him in the stomach and
the dude is trying to grab him and he
tries to hit cart see now he's taking a
break and Alesi stomach heaving yeah
here's know what to do
yeah isn't know how to get out of this
because they're [ __ ] around here's
know how to get it out of this he tries
to grab them the car is like no I'm just
gonna move you go ahead and just gas him
out
come on but his trainer has got to be
going crazy like what in the [ __ ] are
you doing of course you're one of the
top fighters on the planet Earth and
you're here [ __ ] around with a
300-pound giant what did this guy gets
ahold of one of your legs and decides to
rip it apart
exactly exactly that's what I'm talking
about see they punched him in the
stomach huh I guess they're not punching
each other in the face yeah they're
going bare bare knuckle tattoos head his
baton doesn't even fit the body of him
he's getting tired though see cuz all
the flinching he's Connor Connors making
a flinch
he's he's making him move he's fainting
and when you faint like that see he
doesn't know what to do he's given up
thinking about cars not letting him give
up look he's not let him give up it's
like come on [ __ ] now he's gonna get
into some Jiu Jitsu here
no he's just he's looking knees him in
the body Christ he's punched him he's
mean he's not letting him rest you know
you let some rest
Hey look how small goddam yeah yeah see
that guy was done though the good thing
about being that big you don't you can't
go long it's like a muscle car right if
you got a muscle car with a five gallon
engine or a five gallon gas tank and a
big-ass engine you really you don't have
much it's hard for a second yeah yeah
you know your last is someone and then
that's actually fascinating to watch
weird right yeah yeah well you know big
you ever seen a Wolverine
chase off wolves Oh Wolverines are a
little it's like a 35 pound animal
everything gets the [ __ ] away from it
because they're so ferocious they're so
crazy and they feel like no pain
yeah like things can bite them and like
their little chase wolves they'll chase
bears what's the news with Connor by the
way is he throwing out that he wants to
fight someone he wants to fight kabhi
kabhi but he's there trying to set up
look we are most if this in the future
this is March 24th on Tuesday and
everyone's on [ __ ] full lockdown here
they're talking about doing a UFC they
don't know where it's gonna be for
khabib versus Tony Ferguson they're
talking about doing that somewhere
somewhere in another country you know I
told Danish do it on a battleship just
doing a battleship in international
waters fly everybody in the helicopter
[ __ ] cool idea and there's no
organization like the UFC that could
pull that off
yeah you can't do that with like any
other sport no because you don't need
many very many people you just need the
fighters yeah I mean I don't even know
if they're gonna have an undercard and
the more the crazier the setting you're
a fight the more exact it could be like
and there'll be Lions roaming and I
would imagine one of those sheiks that
has you know a trillion dollars does
they do it in my palace the palace you
said Octagon in a giant ballroom dude if
you guys called sheiks and and like do
you want it like they would start a
problem yeah this is no problem at all
this is come on yeah they'll [ __ ]
sanitize the [ __ ] out of couple jets fly
everybody in sanitize the runway just
crates of Lysol absolutely crop duster
planes spray and Lysol over everything
it would be they would do it right
actually I'm sure they have so much
money
yeah I mean they they could do it right
they could test everyone well what do
you do if someone has like is a they're
asymptomatic and they want to fight
anyway and but they test positive yeah
you gotta go you gotta go
what if it's Tony they test positive but
they're asymptomatic too much of it
resting heart rates low everything's
fine
too much of a good do Goldie you're
shedding it man shedding it as you walk
around after he's over we'll just cover
him in a big plastic suit I guess if the
other fighter was like I'm cool with it
yeah me too probably be cool with it too
yeah sure yeah send location bring
medicine if you see
that couple what they did do you see
that today what that so Trump was
talking about Oh angel - yes and then
one of them I want to say the name wrong
so whatever it I forget what it is
exactly what it is what is it's it's
medication that you use on a koi pond
well to kill bacteria that's the one
that they took yes but it's the same
name I think it's called chloroquine the
same name of it but the one for the koi
pond has them like a - and another maja
yeah the same name without the - is
actually a medication it's a medication
for malaria for malaria Coretta parently
holds promise but they took koi pond a
fish tank medicine they took poison yeah
that they took poison that's what they
took and they were like he told us to
take it yeah but he didn't use no it's
not and then they're like we saw it in
our cabinet you think you have [ __ ]
malaria meds we had it in the shed yep
we used it to kill everything in the koi
pond and we figured hell Jed took it and
he's dead well the woman they were
talking to her and they said now it was
funny because the the reporter was
baiting her the reporter was like now
this is you saw President Trump say that
you should take that yeah they were
showing in a lot that's what she said
they were showing it a lot um no it's a
different name - different name you
[ __ ] yeah this is the same beginning
and you just I guys a PA I feel
comfortable saying this public PSA you
probably don't have the cure at home
right now I feel comfortable with you
saying that yeah unless you just got
back from somewhere where you had to
take something for malaria
yeah maybe man maybe maybe you have it
yeah it's a different medication yeah
but people are blaming Trump for that
yeah this just like this game of trying
to get cliques and blaming people for
like Trump did not tell people to drink
koi pond killer no no definitely didn't
do that
he's been hilarious and this well did
you see that one lady we're talking I
was talking about this earlier this is
one lady who is getting she's an
opportunity to talk to Trump
in a press conference mhm and she said
did you hear that one of your one of the
members of your cabinet referred to it
as the come flu you know saw that yeah
and he's like the what say that again
and she was come flu so he makes her say
it and then he goes who who said it and
well I heard someone of yeah you heard
yeah this is the one question you have
right to ask the president United States
during one of the biggest health crisis
the world has ever known
yeah and you were a mildly racist term
is what you want to check in on yeah I
think we're gonna stop to that they want
to call people out yeah he did a thing
yet he must have caught up though
because yesterday he he read a statement
that like I I love our Asian Americans
and well it's because he kept referring
to it as the Chinese I know I know
Chinese virus here II scratched out on
his I saw it yeah wrote Chinese I said
coronavirus Chinese but that's people
have to understand it's also because
he's in fierce negotiations with China
over these trade sanctions there's a lot
more not and he's a combative dude
yeah he'll take you know any chance to
you saw the same lady did it with
Kellyanne Conway mm-hmm same thing same
question yeah and and you know and there
and she's like I'm not gonna get into
speculation here about a guy you don't
know who said it you just you just heard
someone said it and then you know this
lady didn't know Kellyanne Conway's
husband's half asian right so her kids
are quarter asian she's like I'm sure
you don't like you're not saying that
I'm racist towards Asian my children her
Asian yeah like what he what are you
doing isn't that marriage kind of
interesting oh yeah he's hilarious
I mean he's the most outspoken critic he
hates Trump beyond hates beyond aids and
she's his most ardent defender yeah it's
crazy you guys go to bed at night some
people can these some people can be like
liberals and Republicans and live
together fine some people can be like
hunters and deviants and lived in boats
so vocal about their positions don't
under
anyway what do you want to eat like it's
[ __ ] crazy by the way how great would
it have been if Trump or Kellyanne Khan
we had been asked about the kung fu and
they were like are you gonna see this
are you gonna say it's not a funny term
yeah it would be great it would be kind
of great I mean look if it was an
Italian virus yeah and then they call it
the pasta virus yeah I mean would people
who really get mad now probably not
would they go out the meatball but like
what would be the thing ya know the
pizza virus I don't know yeah rigatoni
virus parpadelle a virus it's just I
don't know man
I've read a terrible thing that one lady
said um that some lady she's Asian and
she was at a store and some lady yelled
she had a mask on shield [ __ ] you at her
interface and then she took off her mask
and coughed at her eye at the Asian lady
yeah coughed at her and yelled [ __ ] you
at her see that's when all the racial
jokes stop being yeah they all just want
out the window right there yeah because
there aren't religions out there but
blame an Asian American yeah person of
Asian descent living in America that has
a zero to do with any of this and she'll
be like [ __ ] you because there's people
just looking for an excuse to blame
whatever on someone else and if it's an
Asian person or a Latino person or
whatever the [ __ ] it is or all the
[ __ ] posts you ignorant of post 9/11
all these poor seek peace yes I'm not
yeah it's bad enough that you're doing
that but I'm not even the target yeah
yes who you're trying to reach here
think turbans everyone with the turban
is Muslim because we forget let like you
know the world's full of idiots too
those are the people you really got to
worry about it's you know I don't want
people to die from this disease of
course but I would like us to lose a
significant portion of our [ __ ]
population
it'd be cool if it taught if it like
preyed on low IQ individuals all these
dummies crying not just low IQ because
there's some low IQ people that are
really nice but it would be great if it
was low IQ people who are mean like it's
a disease it only killed races
open Wow mouth-breathing people huh
something about racism just it just
kills people with racism like there's a
gene and it targets that gene and people
are racist they just drop like flowers
there are a lot of older people dying so
it might be working
it's definitely killed a few races in
this last few weeks
imagine if that's like something people
focus on here's one silver lining mauriz
held grand Wizards are gone we went into
the Facebook pages of all the people who
died and 64% were racist
that'd be awesome that would be a nice
silver lining yeah but what about the
other you know no I 36 wasn't just nice
old grannies it's terrible bit I love
their neighbors it's terrible yeah yeah
yeah but this is one of those things
where you can't even crack a joke
because then people oh yeah oh yeah what
about this person and that person just
you just can't listen to them yeah so I
talked to Michael yeah actually I
haven't even talked to him because he's
not talking cuz he can't talk he's just
texting he still [ __ ] up five days ago
thought he was dying um well no I mean
he's been in the hospital for over a
week but five days ago he thought he was
dying he got this what happened he went
to New York he did my podcast right
after he did my podcast that weekend he
had shows at Gotham so he fluid in New
York City did his shows in New York City
was feeling kind of sick and then got it
got pneumonia and the coronavirus at the
same time in New York or in LA when he
got at home so he was feeling kind of
shitty and then it hit him so he
probably had a weakened immune system
right then he's not a boozer so I don't
think he was boozing but you know he
doesn't have any like that you know no
lying health is no no nothing he seems
like a healthy guy yeah shape in shape
yeah works out of law he said he was
killing workouts he said nothing was
wrong with him he said just started
feeling like he had a cold and then flew
home and then BOOM that is double whammy
but he's recovering he's recovering yeah
he's now the we mean he's not gonna die
but he's not out of the woods yet and
some of these people that have gotten
through this disease
have some sort of permanent lung
impairment you no wonder that one that
scared me
I was reading about this guy see if you
can find this guy 2012 gold medalist in
swimming 31 year old guy got it and he
said he's the absolute worst virus he's
ever experienced in his life he said it
was devastating so it's like some people
have a like Idris Elba and there's
nothing yeah asymptomatic ya seem to be
fine well there they are I mean from my
I just spoke to an infectious disease
doctor on the way over here and and
they're saying that you know the that's
one of the big things about the
asymptomatic people it's like they're
essentially what can keep this thing
going for a while because you're
shedding for fifteen days and if you're
if you're not hold up if you're walking
around yeah rushing by people and you're
at the park and you're in the store and
you're you're shedding you're spreading
it
you're a something and then you go home
but you just gave it to you know these
people people then they go home it's
just so weird that some people don't
experience anything and for other people
like this guy who's a 31 year old
Olympic swimmer
Cameron Vanderburgh 2012 Olympic
swimming champion details bout with
coronavirus he's from Africa that
worries from retired South African
Olympic swimmer details of struggle with
coronavirus I mean this guy is super
healthy yeah really really fit he says
he doesn't smoke lives a healthy
lifestyle and he's young he's in the the
least risk demographic create incredible
so you can't really predict how this
will go
he said although the most severe
symptoms extreme fever have eased I'm
still struggling with serious fatigue
and a residual cough that I can't shake
any physical activity like walking
leaves me exhausted for hours this is
crazy
he's 31 and he's a stud I mean you look
lying yeah Olympic swimmer right I mean
talk about cardiovascular shape there's
some of the the most powerful
cardiovascular
fit people on earth and incredible he
said he's been struggling with it for 14
days Jesus Christ by amazing the worst
virus I've ever had yeah this is any
physical activity like walking leaves me
exhausted for hours the loss and body
conditioning has been immense
and can only feel for athletes that
contract covet 19 as it will suffer a
great loss of current conditioning
through the last training cycle
it's funny how he's thinking about it
infection closer to competition being
the worst yeah isn't it funny how he's
thinking about in terms of conditioning
cycles like that's how Olympians think
yeah did you see how I mean they just
agreed to postpone but you've been like
two days ago Tokyo's like we're not
don't even think about it cuz they're
crooks yeah look that whole thing is a
crooked organization yeah yeah they
should pay those athletes they're making
billions of dollars the athletes make
ends at leats make nothing yeah they're
like if you get a sponsorship in a sport
that's popular yeah
then you're alright if you are the top
like if you get to win a gold medal and
everybody pays attention and then you
become like Michael Phelps where
everybody knows your name you can make a
living yeah everybody else is [ __ ]
yeah while those [ __ ] are raking in
billions and billions of dollars
ridiculous it is the grossest thing in
all sorts only the only thing that's
close is college basketball college
basketball and college football were
those guys again
make billions of dollars for those
organizations and make no money for
themselves in and then you have these
people who are like yeah but these guys
get a free education the [ __ ] out of
[ __ ] out of my face [ __ ] out of here
especially football get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah you get a free education when
you get your brain scrambled every day
and your brains scrambled and this like
the football programs at a major
university are so goddamn valuable not
just even monetarily it becomes the
image of the school yes they even get a
high profile school gets more applicants
and you get more people enrolled just
because of that program it's crazy and
it's a dirty
it's a dirty thing that just like keeps
going so it should have been they should
have fixed out a long time ago this guy
should have been able to they should be
getting paid I mean people like whoa how
come other college students don't you
don't have those [ __ ] skills are bad
[ __ ] yeah that's just what they
got yeah if you're winning NCAA
basketball championships for your school
you should be making a shitload of money
because your goddamn school is making a
shitload of money from you and then if
you're like a bad [ __ ] on one of
those teams they sell your jersey oh
yeah yeah yeah you don't make anything
from that they sell your jerseys and
they're like didn't you get that algebra
class for free oh yeah thanks man and we
gave you a tracksuit and shoes
congratulations yeah yeah and if you
even get I think if you get like I mean
you can't get anything Yuki they can't
even hook you up with an apartment dude
it's it's super [ __ ] like NCAA's again
like a super corrupt organization you've
seen that Icarus movie
Icarus documentary which shows how the
IOC yes it shows how how dirty like even
testing is yeah in the Olympics and it
shows how the Russian team in Sochi was
just completely not just cheating but
every one of their athletes they took
their piss and swapped it out for clean
piss all they had a hole in the wall
they transfer piss back and forth - and
there was a Russian team yeah the
Russian TV it is like culturally
built-in to deceive there seriously it's
about winning it is about winning but
it's also like it is lies on every level
well did you hear me talking about
Yoel Romero did you ever hear after the
fight
no the recent one no Dana White gave me
this information they brought in Yoel
Romero because he had a fractured
orbital in one of his fights okay and
they bring him in and then he gets
examined by this doctor and the doctor
calls up the UFC afterwards and said
where did you get this guy and he goes
what do you mean and they're like what's
going because I've never seen anyone
like him
oh yeah he's an amazing athlete no no
I've never seen a human being like this
like this is the most unusual human
being I've ever seen in my 40 years of
practicing medicine
he said his tendons in his eye are four
times larger than a normal person's he
goes his physical structure is different
than any human being I've ever seen in
my life
whoa whoa Cuba
yeah who knows what kind of [ __ ] wacky
experiments they were doing some Russian
pills when he was a kid that's for sure
imagine Yeah right imagine I mean he was
a top of the food chain wrestler he
meddled in literally every single
international wrestling meet he ever
competed it Yoel Romero is a super stud
yeah just a super stud
that was a weird fight though right the
last one is he yes yeah it was a good
fight that crazy we were in an arena
like a week before it hit the fan I know
we were hanging out in Vegas but it was
a little sketchy then remember we were
like everything gonna be okay yeah then
we went to like dinner we didn't went to
my show yeah we hung out and had a show
and then that was probably the last big
show we'll see in a long-ass time I keep
thinking about how I was talking about
today I did all this morning Foner's
today for further special ball hog ball
hogs out on Netflix right in that
favorite by the way is a they had you
called calling has so many radio
stations and this guy's like he goes oh
I'm big instant family fan when are you
gonna do another one and I go what do
you mean he's like I like that show I go
it's a movie
I was it's a movie called instant family
he goes oh yeah when's the next one I
was like the sequel to an adoption film
what like you just tell they're just you
know it's reading [ __ ] off to you but I
was talking to somebody on the on the
press thing today and I go most of us
comics since we've been active working
comedians at a at most two weeks we've
gone without doing stand-up and in that
return you know when you first get on
stage after like a vacation you're like
I just feel [ __ ] weird yeah no you
have like weird butterflies your rhythms
off your pacings a little off you forget
a word or something
because you're just not fresh we might
be 2-3 months
it's never easy easy yeah he's out ever
doing it
yeah March all of March right well when
was your show he shows the beginning of
March March 7th yeah March 7th and 8th
you did the Mirage so all of March all
of April we mean we easily could be deep
into July or August before I did a set
March 11th was my last set mmm and then
March 12th I canceled my had a show you
canceled it too yeah because I was doing
a Spanish show at the belly room mm-hmm
and then yeah I cancelled that and that
was it and everything that moved
yeah the the store said they were gonna
cancel gatherings of Les the the the
state mandate was anything with 200
people or more and the main room I think
holds 400 people
so decide to keep the belly room open
which is I mean the the oor which is one
150 I think yeah something like that
and then they asked me if I want to do a
spot there and I'm like I don't think I
do
I think I'm good I'm like I don't know
what to do here and then I had improv a
couple days later and then I texted The
Improv them like I think we should shut
this down yes it doesn't seem right the
way that it rolled out was funny
business so I had that weekend at the
ice house so I go we'll move that you
know I go what we can't do it so we
moved it following week which would have
been the weekend that just ended I was
supposed to be in Dayton and even on
Monday they were like do you want to do
you want to do on Monday or maybe it was
Friday they're like you could still do
date they were given Swartz Swardson had
some shows in Utah they were giving him
a hard time they were like you know hey
we're gonna lose our shirt if you cancel
he's like um I'm [ __ ] what yeah no
this is guys yeah hey and then I go we
got to move the date so then we move
that and then you know everyday we keep
pushing things month by month
Oh Chappelle was doing shows like real
late really yeah he was doing shows like
the weekend after yours Wow yeah yeah
yeah I don't know oh yeah yeah [ __ ]
big-ass theatres yeah yeah I was I mean
I'm supposed to be in Vancouver on the
20th that's never gonna happen no then
Chappell and I were doing a show in
Nashville and a show in New Orleans
those are not gonna happen that's the
end of April I don't get moved
apparently I mean I hope people get the
opportunity to get a refund because
there's a lot of people right now that
probably bought tickets and like [ __ ] I
need that money right now just for food
and [ __ ] you're totally right how many
people or just have a zero check it's
probably like 50 percent of the
population in Ramos its enormous Lee
devastating to the economy yeah I mean
we had some people working on her house
I had to fix something in the garage I
was like two PR people working are they
allowed to work and everyone's just it's
just doing social distancing and you
know I had some work done and they were
like excited to do it yeah people are
happy to work yeah I've been getting
text messages and emails from people
that are like I mean they had like
viable businesses and they counted on
the money being in there every week and
there was no plan on the table for
anything that involves no one being able
to work of course and why would anybody
be prepared for this no one of course
and no one knows how long did last and
Wow I'm just reading something about
California where they're talking about
like shows and concerts it might be six
months yeah I believe it I mean it's it
is so April May June July August
September we wouldn't do shows until
September it's so weird but I mean what
will it be like all so weird so weird
but I'd be weird for everybody that's
true that's true be weird for the
audience be weird for everybody I keep
thinking too you know we we know all
these people in clubs and like they're
like immediately have no job the server
services what are the chefs yeah the
servers we got to do something for them
at the store for sure because they don't
have any money it's not like they're
comics who have like saved up money and
have no they count on that thousand
bucks in the between those their shifts
every week and you can stepped out and
you know yep yeah yeah it's um it's
[ __ ] weird man and it's gonna be
weird when everything rolls back up
there's a lot of restaurants are gonna
go under a lot of businesses yeah
I think I heard something about the
Marriott CEO giving up his all his
salary and everything just to like give
it to some of the oh that's nice I think
I think about maybe I'm plugging the
wrong guy but one of the CEOs was like
you know just push it on down yeah I
have a buddy man who runs a production
company and he had a layoff 30 people
yesterday and he was just like he goes
and there's no money coming in everyone
no one's paying him everything shut down
and you know and these workers were like
why don't you just pay us while we're
not working is work cuz I'm making you
money right it's like what do you want
me to do like I don't know what you want
me doing that was like weird
conversation because he was he was like
what am I supposed to do and I'm like I
don't I don't I hope but never
experienced that yeah I don't know what
you're supposed to do know it because I
don't know how much he's not rich yeah
it's a real dilemma man yeah because if
he's right he's running a production
company right yeah so he has a huge
overhead he has cameramen and trucks and
post-production facilities and all this
different stuff and it's all dependent
on money coming in and then when the
money doesn't come in and the payroll
keeps coming out like you go dry wet eel
quick yeah I mean even if you have even
if you have some money there's a there's
a limit to how long you could do that
for yeah yeah yeah season it but people
that work for you
I guess just assumed you make more money
you got enough money to pay me keep
paying me he's like I'm not rich he's
like I barely you know feels like I make
enough money every year to live a good
life but yeah not to pay 30 people where
there's no money yeah Japan you're
paying 30 people let's just say they get
a hundred grand here mmm that's so much
money
yeah there's so much money yeah what
that would be three million yeah right
like that gone yeah no I mean you have
to be able to have come and we have a
staff you know we make podcasts yeah and
we're continuing to do podcast so we can
keep paying the staff yeah that's weird
right we can keep doing this yeah and
then you got to think also like if
someone's doing that and you have you
know 30 people that you're laying off
those people have to get unemployment
how much unemployment is there it's a
record number by 4 times the amount has
ever been filed and it all filed like in
within the same like 72 hours I'm not
too long way they have to pay those
people I'm sure it's not enough I'm sure
they don't have enough to pay the think
the numbers come out Thursday I'm like
the new ones the first numbers of like
this is how many people have to have a
job now the numbers gonna be crazy
it could be nuts it's gonna be crazy and
what is this quarter gonna look like
like on the books this one and the next
one actually this is you gotta assume
let's let's be conservative and say 40
percent of the country's out of work
that's conservative right it's a good
question I'm not really sure I don't
know it's I mean I would be something
like that like forty million people that
we're working probably at least aren't
or not working right now
that we're working and this is worldwide
oh that numbers way [ __ ] higher yeah
I mean just in this country but
worldwide it's like half the sizes are
really like we are not at a real locked
up some places have really locked down
yeah we were talking about that before
the podcast yeah did you see the Italian
mayor's screaming at everybody stay the
[ __ ] home yeah there's a video
compilation I'll send it to Jamie it's
it's actually pretty funny there's a
video compilation of all these Italian
mayor's [ __ ] screaming at people to
stay the [ __ ] home my cousin and Peru
said you can't walk your dog in Lima
right now so where's your dog [ __ ] I
guess in the house or something or
regulations if Marshall out of [ __ ] in
the house we'd have a real issue first
of all he'd be so confused he was you
sure you want me to start doing this I
black dude trust me just [ __ ] right
there is it are you guys
nobody leaves their home no because I
seen it's an order so watch out
[Music]
incontinent dogs you need to stay at
home
people are dying don't you get it this
is super Italian what a beautiful
language it's a beautiful language the
best it's I mean it's interesting how
like American language like the American
the sound that we make you think won't
the way we speak English in America it's
it stop writing me letters useless
Daniel you'll be just fine
all these hairdressers coming to your
homes someone come with your house they
came to my house and that's been to
other people's houses rigatoni virus is
killing us everybody rigatoni virus
girl yeah where's your neck
where are your hand gestures sure what
yeah mayor who are you what kind of
Italian you not feeling this guy get out
of your pencil neck ciao did I got sea
shut him off Jamie yeah it's well italy
is losing hundreds and hundreds of
people a day like yesterday it was like
five hundred they said yesterday was the
the first day where the number dipped
yeah but i mean it's never before 500 a
before was eight hundred day before
seven hundred yeah it's been going it's
been nuts but they do have the second
oldest population of a major country in
the world and a giant population of
smokers yeah all smoke over there
and then all day long every greeting is
miss you know yeah affection there i'll
baton each other smoke and
fingering each other yeah yeah yeah I go
to Italy every summer
yeah mmm not this summer not this summer
no maybe it'd be good discount [ __ ]
great discount that country by the way
like I mean a huge part of that GDP is
tourism yeah you know like I mean I want
to say like over 15% mm-hmm so it's
gonna be slammed for this no it's it's
weird it's like you wonder what what
does a country do to sort of mitigate
the issues that are being caused by that
the only thing I keep thinking about how
like when you think about how badly so
many places are doing is just that
everybody else is doing poorly you know
I mean yes it's not one place this is a
worldwide pandemic so yeah and that's
the only you can think of yeah there's
the only thing you think it's it's a
strange strange time for us I'm hoping
that on the other end we come out of
this with a little perspective you know
the people that survive come out of this
with a little perspective like hey we
got it good we got it real [ __ ] good
I think that perspective will last about
seven days months yeah yeah people will
be like in New York it lasted a few
months yeah that's true I think I think
it was more special in here it'll affect
Italians for a long time you know places
that are devastated by it yeah I think
so but I mean yeah people you know are
usually humans are just are gonna react
to the current condition you yeah that's
the problem with us we're we get real
comfortable I saw that that uh the
somebody tweeted or something that this
whole thing is the Earth's vaccine and
were the virus who said somebody someone
trying to be profound someone trying to
be profound but then you start looking
there like you know pollutions down the
water is cleaner the you know the fish
are swimming in the canals of Venice
again good point good point they have a
point well look at Los Angeles air
quality better than it's been ever for
sure it's amazing no one's driving yeah
yeah but also no one's eating yeah oh
there's that part yeah this the way we
live is ridiculous and our ridiculous is
not even as bad as New York's ridiculous
New York's ridiculous is the most
ridiculous
because there's literally stacked on top
of each other yeah there's no getting
away from anybody they have the most
ridiculous way of life and they love
that life you know they love the fact
that they can go to a hundred different
restaurants at midnight yeah you know
sure and it's great to be I mean I love
being around it I like to visit yeah it
is fun but I mean I would hate to be
cooped up there right now
Oh would be terrible terrible I really
get out of the city yeah well Ari bailed
yeah yeah I was telling you earlier he
went down to Maryland it was hilarious I
was like don't tell ya he likes to keep
his woman in the dark doesn't know the
extent of this she doesn't have a
[ __ ] phone yeah he's like no you
don't see em that's why they get along
so good she's like she balances him out
in strange way he is so funny too in
that he of course was like [ __ ] five
days ago
I know I've really [ __ ] and freaked
out about yeah it's 24 hours later he's
like I gotta get out of the city what
are you guys doing how do you guys
keeping social distancing I'm like wait
what's going on here how did you switch
someone well we're this text group group
text that we're in we were all like hey
what happened yeah what happened over
the last 24 hours
yeah well couple people got freaked out
so I freaked out like who freaked you
out it's a weird time man but I get
I bet for Burt's special and for your
special this is gonna be [ __ ] Banzai
it's so bizarre the hunties not a good
word bonanza a bonanza is what I meant
to say it is bizarre that so many people
are forced to be home yeah and they've
already announced that all the the views
are up I don't know they have to
throttle streaming yeah yeah yeah I mean
but I've noticed it too on podcasts like
downloads are up the user oh yeah you
know yeah and you know it also kind of
keeps him sane it's like your show like
your mom's house or this podcast or in
these podcasts that people subscribe to
it's a part of their routine so yes at
least there's some normalcy and I don't
want to overplay that make it seem like
we're doing some great service no but
there's something that does give people
some comfort I think they really let
it's that
molarity of like I listen to Joe show
it's on this makes me just distract me
from from you know the chaos for a
little bit I mean I guess that's why
we're allowed to do it because we're
we're considered part of media yeah you
know yeah I think it's funny that my
show is like well who farted loudest
today but it is I mean look if the
[ __ ] regular news that horse [ __ ] if
that's yeah yeah yeah
you know if that's media we're
definitely media yeah yeah I know I
don't know these I think with the time
and like wisdom and having experienced
and observed media for a while now and
you get to like a traumatic thing like
this a pandemic you I really look at I
watch news I've always consumed a lot of
news I'm like so much of this is just
ridiculous sensationalism you know it
really is all that same there's no
there's no different the big news
organizations then those [ __ ] click
things yeah it's almost like new should
be nonprofit I got a [ __ ] breaking
story for you I forgot well I I cannot
believe I almost forgot this ooh
so you know the guy in those texts that
the big black guy yes yeah let's explain
that is a trick people always say the
link oh my god it's it's now killing
more 20-year olds than any disease every
like what what he clicked the link and
there's this jack black dude with a dick
that looks like my leg sitting on the
edge of the bed nothing like he's like
have you seen a bigger dick that's what
his expression is when it's limp its
limp yeah there is area yeah so yeah
this is Bram knows he's dead right he's
dead he died a few years ago so and by
the way that the the that meme of like
kind of has gone viral I mean right
every I mean you know I get 25 a day
from different people I have a doctor
friend who sends me I'm like Jesus right
so it's like it's not just in like
gravity sort and I'm sure people
listening or watching have have have
seen it as well so I was like meh who is
this [ __ ] guy right like I know you
kind of just get curious
keep seeing this and it's like sort of
like this sense of relief from the
seriousness of the day right you'll be
having you just seen like these people
to hide and you know quarantined and
then you get this ridiculous text and
it's this guy so I saw an article where
the photographer who took that photo was
like ah he was like oh it's so sad that
people are using his image that way
because you know he passed away and and
I you know he thought it was kind of
offensive that he was being used to
prank or whatever and he said you know I
I saw that people started selling merch
with this guy's face on it and I he goes
I just wish he goes I own the photograph
and I'm not trying to come after him
when I just wish they would share
proceeds of that merge with the family
so I saw that and I was like oh I want
to do that so I launched a shirt with
that guy's face on it that says wash
your hands and then and then I go I go I
want to give the proceeds to this man's
family so because of that article I
reached out to people I was able to get
in touch with the photographer the guy
who took that picture and then I found I
got in touch with his the the models
fiance who you know his XP I mean
whatever he passed away so anyways I
contacted her I found her I've learned a
little bit about this guy in that photo
and I'm giving them the proceeds from
the shirt sales all of them all the
profits will go to them and I also found
that when he when he died like the
family wasn't prepared like financially
for anything so they had to set up a
GoFundMe for his funeral and tombstone
and all that so I'm I'm gonna blast it
out but I talked beautiful they're happy
with it so that's my breaking news
that's the break that's the break that's
important news Jamie told me his dicks
not really as big I didn't get into that
with her I Jamie said that it's
photoshopped I've heard that as well
seen I saw the original blog post it
came from you
let's see what the original heart I
don't have to find it now oh please
don't tell me that's gonna take a while
you pull it up let's see the original
hog please
he's Google it so like I have to find
the link just Google original big penis
guys I'm sure that show me the original
black dick yeah but she is funny she was
like you know what was crazy is when I
reached it I found it took me like I was
doing like detective work right now
tough to find her and she was like I
found out about this meme today oh she
was like I didn't even know this was a
thing how did she find out people are
not sending it to her I think so yeah
and then someone was like husband yeah
yeah yeah anyways yeah oh well first of
all she's engaged to a porn star that's
got no but she wasn't she wasn't no
she's lying to me she goes you know he
was she goes he did those photos when it
was a really bad time in his life he
needed money to save the house that he
grew up in that was his now oh so he
just starts slinging that big deck yeah
started stealing that dig around and how
much money can make slinging dick is a
dude I think if it yeah I don't fifty
bucks no I think you can get more than
that they make much money I think the
girls make the money and even they don't
make much money
true it is crazy when you think about in
terms of like you did a blow bang for
500 like that raising a mine yeah but if
you need the money then you're gonna
lose gonna see that yeah that's what if
it's a good one people will pass it
around I saw the clip once of it was
like after a scene was shot and then the
girl was like is anybody gonna see this
and they were like they all started look
each other like yeah it's going on the
internet she goes no I don't want it to
be there and they're like that's what
you signed up for she started to cry
No
yeah if someone's really dumb and they
wind up doing porn mm-hmm they don't get
it like what do you mean you saw it how
you weren't there
how did you see it how did you see it I
went online Oh No can other people see
it yeah yeah and they have well here's
the crazy thing the sheer number of
porns like how many porno videos are
there dude
it's like and how much are they how much
are you cranking out every day you go to
any of those sites it's just like
everyday they're like here's 10,000 more
I just have a bit about who's why they
make a new porn cuz no one's seen all of
them yeah it's not like movies we have
to follow the plot right jerked off to
every porn ever I mean no one it has to
be some people's world though or they're
just like so well some guys get obsessed
with a girl yeah you know and then they
want women when are you coming out with
new content yeah and they go to those we
fan the meetups you know the whole see
the billboards in LA yeah dope combos
yeah yeah and they always show like
footage of those like with the hot
chicks and the guys that's where the
next coronavirus is coming from those
guys those guys sweaty handed dudes all
those guys look like they're in [ __ ]
tiger King that I've seen that Netflix
yes isn't it amazing amazing I only got
halfway into it though and I had I had a
microphone call yeah I'm three in
unbelievable had to watch the rest of it
how do you lose his legs spoiler type
wine accident he said no do you see that
bad [ __ ] though who got her arm and she
was like went back to work five days
later she was like I was never upset
about it you know what tiger bit off
your [ __ ] arm you weren't upset and
she's taking their film on her with a
stub you know like what what's going on
with her and that cameras on the guy Joe
exotic yeah as it's happening he's like
I'm never gonna finally recover from
this is it Menken yeah they're gonna
financially recover how about the one
they're talking about shutting them down
like this gonna be bigger than Waco oh
god yeah what yeah sure people if they
try to take your Tigers yeah he would
I'm sure he would do
it's it literally is my my bit from my
last know my triggered Netflix special
my 2016 Netflix pressure will come to
life
yeah that bit about Tigers in Texas yeah
so you could just have them yeah I had a
bit about I had a bit years before that
about the Ohio all the guy had about
that used to be like one of my that guy
blew his brains out right just let it
let everybody out of the cage and then
blew his brains out deal with this
let tiger's eye on that footage and and
seen the guy give the press conference
he's like he reads he's like this cat
and then he looks up he's like and
sixteen lions like he's like [ __ ] and
they just had a run around and gunned
him down
oh my god it was game hunters
there's lucky that got them all yeah
that's just it's this they're not
prepared for that in the same way cops
are not trained for combat
people forget that like when there's
these big shootings and they're like why
didn't the cops go in there they're not
trained for that
remember the North Hollywood shootout
yeah of course I was on Newsradio at the
time and we were all held up in the
[ __ ] we were in the break room
watching it we were like what the [ __ ]
we were like eating looking up at this
camera where these guys wearing armored
vests and if I powered rhyme 16 I should
yeah shooting at cops crazy that that I
remember I was in high school and and I
was watching that and I was like that's
what California only happen in
California yeah people don't know that
was a that was a game-changer that was a
bank robbery where guys had like fully
automatic machine guns
yeah and armored vehicle didn't have
armored vehicles but they have like full
bulletproof vests and suits and yeah and
they were fully locked they were on
steroids and coke and it was like
real-life grand theft auto ship men like
real life yeah like shooting these uh
fully automatic guns at helicopters and
[ __ ] too and but anybody that came in
the way yeah I remember there was one
where they coked up and everything
though
sure there was one activist that was
upset because the cops let one guy bleed
out there like they could have taken him
to the hospital and they chose not to
like what the [ __ ] is wrong but it made
me realize like there's gonna be people
that complain about everything no matter
what everything everything yeah and they
just want to be heard it's like they
just want they didn't want to have a hot
take yeah on things mm-hmm
and they and they're just waiting for
the the group of people that go like
good point yeah that feels bad always
gonna be people to do that too yeah yeah
there's so many of us there's always
gonna be someone that agrees with your
stupid point yeah that's true
yeah that's that's what that's what like
social media thrives off oh yeah I have
a stupid point to make he also agrees
with me there's always someone no matter
what there's always something like you
can have the most ridiculous point
mm-hmm there's gonna always gonna be
someone it's like I'm with him this it's
just a numbers game yeah and then they
find those people and then they get on a
reddit page some somewhere and they all
get together and then they agree with
each other yeah then they think are the
rest of world's [ __ ] and then they
they just have this echo chamber yeah
people love doing that I mean that's
what flat earthers do sure I mean if you
watch that doc on rocket man did you
watch him die I watched the did you see
Rocket Man die no wait you wanna see
that okay yeah he shot that rocket up in
the air to try to prove that the earth
was flat and they didn't fasten the
parachute correctly to the capsule and
so the parachute goes off with the
initial launch oh [ __ ] yeah the
parachutes gone like right away and then
it falls down here it goes watch wait so
test set up what's happening here so
this guy he decided he was gonna prove
that the earth was flat so he built a
rocket and launched himself up into the
air he had done it once before but this
time he launched himself really high to
try to film the earth so watch boom look
others there she's gone Oh
he shoots straight up in the air
and then like oh my god what is this
breaking news at least [ __ ] idiots so
watch it it comes down right here there
it is oh so that's he's on that full
speed on the way down and he's waiting
for the parachute go off boom yeah no
parachute mmm just boom experiment go
not good not good or perfect how did how
did these guys really think that I mean
how [ __ ] dumb are you
they're pretty dumb but here's the other
thing how gross is it that in a video
like that you have to have like and
coming up next I have some respect you
[ __ ] Jesus Christ it's uh you know did
you think you know like the like that
crazy [ __ ]
have you seen like Tom Hanks's comments
about coronavirus you know the comments
in his posts no dude all the top
comments are like you are a pedophile
you [ __ ] all these kids and it's like
like dozens of them yes Tom Hanks well
because there's like that there's like
flat earthers I'm saying there's the
people who are like Hollywood is a
pedophilia conspiracy it is I mean I cuz
I want to just be like oh what's you
know is he recovering I just saw his
went to his page it's just some Twitter
no Instagram and it's like significant
number of them and like with hundreds
and thousands of likes and what yes I've
never heard this it's so straight Tom
Hanks is a I think they think that any
high a list Hollywood person
automatically oh he's a pedophile son
responded did you see that no no I did
not like has made those weird videos
last recently like yeah the regular
voice and stuff yeah he made a video
trolling everyone saying like we're in
the Illuminati oh that's funny
and like oh it's true my parents got
coronavirus crazy they're both down in
Australia right now because my dad was
shooting a movie down there but the
Instagram comments fine they're not even
that sick dude they're not worried about
it they're not tripping but they're
going through the
certain health precautions obviously but
I don't think it's anything to be too
worried about I appreciate everyone's
concern and this is not the one where
you talked about the Illuminati mmm hey
guys I'm really stressed out right now
it's been coming to my attention that a
lot of Trump supporters have been
figuring out the truth about me and my
family you know being in the you know
what I'm talking about and I don't know
what to do right now because
everything's starting to come to light I
mean these extremely reliable websites
like 4chan Ahn have been exposing [ __ ]
and it's like if somebody wrote it on
the internet you know it must be true
and it is true so it's like I don't know
how this is gonna affect our whole new
world agenda
ever since the Simpsons predicted my dad
being the spokesperson for the
coronavirus even though they didn't
predict anything is it's just been it's
been troublesome to say the least
I guess I'm just gonna have to work
extra hard at my human sacrifices I'm
late for one right now and I'm a little
hungry so I might eat someone's pen okay
okay yeah why does he have that
all-seeing eye tattooed in the middle of
his chest he's a lot of tattoos it's a
weird chore
what do you got there Thomas I was
looking at a I was pulled up the bankses
comments like they're they're so
outrageous you know it's like what what
started it off it's it's this whole
concept that like any a list Hollywood
type I don't know what the origin is of
that but if it's like you know Spielberg
Hanks crew like getting those big-time
names they're like you're part of the
pedophile ring it's just that's how they
get to be huge you have to be a part of
the pedophile ring I guess become a big
movie star I think so
it's so exhausting yeah it's so
exhausting these [ __ ] people it's
exhausting again we need a disease it
kills morons this could be it I don't
think it is no yeah if they're
invulnerable what if I was like a
disease that literally lowers over an IQ
of the world like it's like if you're
really smart you just die of dying oh my
god well this is a weird disease too
because my friend dr. Peter Atia he said
there there's
some speculation that it might be
related to genetics and blood type
people that are more vulnerable to it
right as an o-type o+ seems to be the
least vulnerable and a seems to be the
most vulnerable interest i don't even
know what type should know i don't know
my doctor you should find out bro if
you're vulnerable hmm
and then don't let bert sneeze on you
he's gonna survive everything everything
he'll be fine I know at the end of the
vol he'll be like 85 I really do hope
this is a wake-up call for him and he
gets off those [ __ ] medications we
talked about it yesterday yeah
getting off blood mmm blood pressure
medication doesn't mean [ __ ]
no he's fat he's needs to stop being fat
if he stopped drinking so much he
wouldn't need blood pressure medication
he's [ __ ] boozing every night if he
just took three months off and exercised
and ate well and didn't drink [ __ ]
and didn't eat sugar I guarantee you you
wouldn't need any of that well this is
actually quite that the benefit of this
is that you know where he really goes
the hardest is on the road yes the road
really [ __ ] with him we talked about
that yesterday like I asked if he was a
prisoner to this sort of image that he's
created and he's like kind of yeah
definitely yeah I mean that party animal
images it's unsustainable it's also he
doesn't you know he has that personality
where he doesn't want to let somebody
down so if somebody even if he's done
for the night he's like all right I'm
definitely going in yeah and somebody's
like hey man one more shot yeah will you
Han arrest Thompson fan and all no I
never I never really you know got into
it was exposed to it that much um big
fan of his and when he died one of the
saddest things was watching the
interviews before he died
because he was a heavy Boozer drug yeah
yeah I know that deep into his 60s right
yeah I think how old was he when he died
he was in the 70s when he died it was he
70s how it was her as tops when he died
what are you doing I finally just found
that link and other guys original dick
they took me till [ __ ] I'm deep on
the internet right now oh do you want to
see where I'm at or
we'll just show the dick let's see the
original dick now he's like it's deep
brother it's huge
it's a different picture but that's a
different picture it's the same photo
shoot right but where's the the actual
photo where you see whoa
scroll down keep scrolling oh this is a
know your meme thing guys a giant dick
there dude don't know what you're
talking about with the same one it's a
different well that's a weird angle
right there any way you could make that
bigger so we can looks like it's not a
small dick I think you're wrong Jamie I
think it's the same hard muscle bear Oh
muscle bear so he was doing that kind of
porn yeah oh okay
I think he's doing looks like he's doing
solo shots you know okay pictures of me
yeah there's a lot of money in that
maybe I don't know starting only fans
Jamie um well what were we just talking
about before that we were talking about
Burt and partying and [ __ ] on to the
road not being on the road yeah we
passed that though we're talking about
new stuff people at home were screaming
we're not even high how about that no my
memory sucks
you'll be being a prisoner though to
that Oh hundreds Thompson Connor how
cesari's when he was oh how old was he
when he died that's the question when he
died you barely could understand a word
he was saying because he was so he would
just stumble all his words into
gathering 67 that's incredible I think I
remember that didn't he kill himself
after a football game no he killed
himself because NFL was over what's that
mean well there was no NFL because after
the Super Bowl or something right wasn't
he's got no argument with his wife he
shot at her with a pellet gun and then
went inside and blew his brains out
something you know something along those
lines but when he died before he died he
would go on Conan and you know take
Conan with him in the backyard and have
you ever seen those videos yeah this
house of Woody Creek which is outside of
Aspen and he would shoot guns out there
and had Conan come and visit him and you
could barely understand a word he was
saying
he was so [ __ ] up it's like his his
ability to express himself was just gone
it was just all the words blurred and
mumbled together it's in danger of that
kind of thing sure are
20 years from now if he keeps going hard
in the paint every night I mean when
Hunter was in his 40s he was fine yeah
yeah when hunter was in his 40s is when
he was running for sheriff I think I
think maybe his 30s I don't know it's
just that life of boozing is so
unsustainable yeah the pot smoking thing
is so sustainable it's so shocking like
you talked at Tommy Chong he's fine he's
been he's like 80 years old yeah it's
been smoking pot his whole life he can
talk to you fine yeah
but the booze will wear on you who's
crushes you that's true
what was the other author the guy really
got [ __ ] up Bukowski yeah man and why
did he die was it alcoholism was no way
no is that I don't know but I remember
he looked like [ __ ] [ __ ] he looked
like hell yeah remember Mickey work
played him in that movie barfly uh-uh
you don't remember
no yeah Miki work and Faye Dunaway I
just remember a reward for leukemia
leukemia I'm probably related to alcohol
but when he I remember the footage of
when the documentary crew was in his
house mouse keys like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah kick Cernik the girl yeah that's
how they rocked it all day long that was
the way they lived yeah yeah that white
trash romanticized white trash boozy
life it's very strange because he was a
brilliant poet yeah he would write
interest
[ __ ] and you'd go wow that look post
office and fantastic no yeah he's a lot
of great stuff great short pieces yeah
but you know his life was just gross
yeah dude yeah it was Hollywood gross
you know like living in Hollywood just
going to the bars bars bars yeah smoking
and talking slow huh man I know I can't
a man I mean thinking about it makes me
feel sick like to be in bars just
drinking and smoking all day all day
yeah just going to bars and talking [ __ ]
yeah like he there's some funny videos
of him reading reading his stories read
and like doing public readings and
people are interrupting him he's
threatening to stab them yeah yeah he
was he was a while dude yeah yeah yeah I
mean but that was part of his appeal
part of his appeal was that here's this
guy it's like he's not trying to be
commercially successful he's not trying
to buy a mansion and have a big yard
offense he's just living in some shitty
apartment drinking heavily mm-hmm and
just cranking out work
I remember reading his stuff for the
first time and just being like I didn't
know anybody who wrote like this yeah
cuz of how like he would be so vulgar
yeah I know yeah I really liked it
you should see barfly yeah I should it's
weird Mickey Rourke plays he does a
weird take on him to a toast or my
friend he's always getting in fights
he's like at this bar getting [ __ ] up
and getting in fights can't his ass
character but it's this it's just this
agreement that everyone has like
everyone's [ __ ] up and you're all just
gonna meet together at this place and be
[ __ ] up together
yeah and live your fucked-up lives yeah
it's wrong yeah I don't know man it's
not for me
but I enjoy watching it do you have
moments with Burt were you were we're
alone with them off-camera
we try to talk some sense into him about
like his crazy
got the booze yeah yeah sure yeah I've
talked to him before about it I mean you
know the thing about him is that he's so
like high-functioning and he he's he is
the perfect person to be he has the
perfect defense of like I'm fine because
he he can do so much and you know he's
not sleeping in he's getting up you know
with with the kids for school he's going
on tour Joey says he goes back to bed
does he
yeah I don't know that he goes back to
bed he's drinking at 11:00 he goes back
to bed yeah
how's it Joe he said I go really yeah
tell she gets up with the kids that
[ __ ] sleeps till 2:00 in the
afternoon
really he goes right right back to bed
Joey told me that he doesn't got too
[ __ ] up the other day
dude no he's like even me I go what
happened he like fight some 400
milligram thing I fell asleep vicodin no
no no for no like millions of th oh he's
like Tom Segura you know he says you
know you're full [ __ ] name yeah stops
ago I had my M&Ms in my teeth on the
sleep apnea machine so he was like it
was bad my wife saw me and she was like
what are you doing he was what do you
prefer that I do this so I'm out there
robbing people yeah and she was like
good point those aren't the two options
you have if anybody if I had a magic
wand and one person to fix their
lifestyle it would be Joey it would be
clean clean up his diet yeah that's
gotta be as unhealthy as Bert if not
more this is he's so big and you know
he's 60 years old almost you can't you
can't last being that big and he this is
already it but he's already in a much
better place than he was 10 years prior
right yes but well no ten years ago he
lost a shitload of weight okay there was
one point time where he lost like 80
pounds yeah remember he said my head
looked too big he that was like oh yeah
I got a gained weight again reasoning
for gaining weight but he can do it yeah
like red band did that too red band got
really skinny red band got down low yes
160 he did remember that
yes and then I went a long time without
seeing him I saw him again he put on a
bunch yeah but he's the Cape I mean
we're all capable of it you know I go up
and down all the time I'm just like you
know for me you can always tell if I'm
gaining weight it's not exercise for me
it's that I started eating sugar again
mm-hmm you know like I worked out like
crazy last year I got there was points
where I was working out like out of 75
days I work out like 62 of them you know
well but I was not dropping weight
because we eating I was eating yeah yeah
you want a reward for all that hard work
amount yes cake yeah and then I also
sometimes it's not even the cake it's
like I'll just you'll see somebody who
works out a lot and eats like a large
balanced diet and I'll be like well I
want to do that you know you should do
eat nothing but duck eggs the whole
month there's so much weight gooey jizz
in my mouth oh so much weight but I have
two little boys he make me eat a duck
egg you're really gonna [ __ ] the duck
egg industry we just suck my dick I'm
gonna stick to chicken eggs better
they're better no such things are okay
maybe people are in know maybe I cooked
him wrong I'm sorry duck egg people yeah
they're you're gonna get some messages
about that but I have to do that the
protein fat thing I have to yeah like
the only way that I'll not blow up did
you quit the carnivore diet yeah
how long did you last I did it hardcore
for about a month and then I did how
long before the diarrhea in a way that
was about 10 days I got a text from you
this diarrhea astonish a was it was her
diary astonished I have photos my phone
that I saved cuz I'm like this is crazy
I have ink the other word like real
special diarrhea that I had was when you
know so I went from like just doing that
hardcore to having like some greens but
like meat you know meat fat and then
like some greens that was fine it was
when I that first day of like I [ __ ] it
gonna have some pasta and a donut today
and then it was
like just immediately crazy shits crazy
shits buddies like make up your mind
yeah I'm here to punish oh no I had to
hold on to the side of the seat they
watch it was like Rocket Man really
really a good extraordinary mmhmm yeah
yeah there's a volume that's astonishing
right it's like that mountain it comes
out like I don't even eat that much you
would know too you had like this warning
your stomach does things it tells you
like you're gonna want to sit down for
this one
yeah like there's like little explosions
yeah and you when you feel the liquid
you feel water in your gotcha I think i
strengthen my [ __ ] muscles though
that's good because I I was clamping him
down so often was likes and then I
barely made it to toilet that is yeah
this is I just never saw it coming cuz
most of what I was eating before was
kind of carnivore esque and then I would
have like a little bit of vegetables or
some pasta or some planked out but I
lost 12 pounds in a month in a month and
just got shredded pretty easy and I kept
most of it off yeah
I gained maybe three or four cuz I went
back to eating pasta and bread and
during this quarantine I'm not on any
diet I'm just because I'm my concern is
just I mean what if it's hard to get
food yeah you know I want to make sure
that I'm just eating food yeah I'm not
I'm not thinking about the way I look or
I don't think diet is a real big concern
I mean you know I'm not trying to let go
off the rails but it's no yeah yeah I
lost ten on the in that month oh that's
pretty good yeah yeah yeah if you just
cut out the sugar you just feel so much
better - you do and you and I see the
[ __ ] I see the dark cycle that
happens when you start I start with
sugar like when I start being like odd
this today in that tomorrow oh yeah
double stuff or you and then I realized
that like I don't even want it but I'm
craving it you know yeah yeah
and I if I couldn't yeah there's the
thing that I get when I'll eat carnivore
well have a big steak right so I'll eat
a steak and then I'm done I'm done
eating but unless I want a cookie then I
could have more room yeah more room for
that cookie yeah yeah or pasta I got
more room for that pasta it's incredible
in the carnivore thing the amount that I
can eat and not feel like that stuff
feeling yeah at all at all like again
when II 2 ounce [ __ ] t-bone and you
feel fine feel fine you don't feel
wrecked no yeah it's the best feeling
after food because you don't feel like
you [ __ ] up yeah you feel like you
like you have all your mental capacity
you have your full mental capabilities
you can think and talk and when I eat a
big bowl of ate lasagna or something I'm
not talking to nobody about nothing no
if you talk to me I don't know what I'm
saying I'm just going what yeah rain
shuts down and I start to go like like
those types of verbs the guy starts to
like push out door and then I'll start
ripping crazy farts like I farted lapse
Pristina made this pasta dish and last
night I farted so crazy she goes do you
even respect me anymore like I was like
yeah but I mean this is what's going on
this happens this is marriage understand
farts yet oh yeah
well like my oldest will be like you're
a fart and he's four and he loves him he
talks about him and he even has that
thing that like like the almost implied
shame like did you just fart it's like
no I didn't fart you [ __ ] like he
knows that like you know I mean like you
don't want to be right the farter yeah
but and then my my young is what 20
months you fart he's like he's just like
nods and smiles he thinks it's great
he thinks it's great farts are always
gonna be funny with some kids yeah just
one of those things to little boys man
they just they love it yeah yeah you got
little savages I did it my oldest is
like he called me a little [ __ ] the
other day whoa and threw little in there
he goes you little [ __ ] and I was like
hey
what over what it was like hey no you
can't have that right now he was like oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] what was that he goes you
little [ __ ] no I go you don't do that
you don't do that daddy you do that for
a living yeah exactly
then he goes well you're a jerk I know
you don't call me that either were you
getting this yeah
call me a [ __ ] [ __ ] what are you gonna
let him watch you on stunned on
television I've you know I've tried to
do it for a moment to see like what his
interest I'll be like hey check this
who's this
and it'll be like me and I'll show it so
and he's like yeah anyway and he just
immediately he's like put the [ __ ]
paw patrol back on your right here right
in front of me what I give a [ __ ] if
you're on the phone yeah doesn't care
one day he's gonna appreciate it one day
what how are you kids into it yet they
they get weirded out but then they see
people approach you did you not like
that yeah they do not like that yeah my
littlest especially does not like that I
like because people don't pay attention
to her they just start talking to me and
if she's talking to me people interrupt
her to talk to me he gets a really angry
pull on me yeah that makes sense that
makes sense
I all just saw it somebody talking to me
and he just looked he was like they
walked away he was just I could tell he
wanted to be like what was that all a
bit do you know that guy yeah yeah it's
like my kids always said do you know him
I'm like no like but he he comes up to
you like he knows you
oh yeah like he took him awhile to
figure out they've never seen me perform
but one time we were all in Irvine
together and I was doing the improv and
I snuck them backstage I'm like you want
to see what the crowd looks like and
then like they like peek behind the
counter they're like oh my god so many
people well yeah I go this and this is
only a comedy club this isn't even a
theater and it's not even an arena yeah
it's crazy
yeah one I want them to come to an arena
one day that was you have to because
it's so bonkers of course it's got it's
gonna blow their mind yeah yeah they'd
be like wait a minute wait a minute
there's view people yeah who knows what
that'll ever happen again
I know who knows yeah this look no one
saw this coming
I mean people that put on like concerts
and sporting events and entertainment is
completely other than this kind of [ __ ]
yeah this is it yeah this is it yeah
somebody was and I saw these ideas cuz
people were you know doing virtual
performance you know whatever you can go
live and play a guitar or sing and
they're like people like you should do
like virtual comedy shows I'm like and
you have to have the live audience
what's that dude's name that did that
one comedy special Jerrod Carmichael
filmed it no I don't know his name but I
know you talked that was no audience
comment yeah so it's a strange concept
terrible idea yeah yeah when Gerard was
telling me I was like what yeah what are
you gonna do well I think the idea of
the audience is played out like the
audience then I said you mean the most
important part of a comedy show the fact
there's people there - laughs yes it's
funny I think they took a swing yeah I
didn't work out I mean I guess you know
I respect taking high risk you know
that's a dumb risk though yeah that's
like I'm gonna swim but with no water
what are you thinking I'm gonna swim in
the bottom of the pool I'm just gonna
see who can just do swimming motions
yeah see how fast I can get across the
pool oh it's it is strange I mean like
that's one that I never thought somebody
would try to do I never thought HBO
would go great idea HBO signs off on a
lot of outrageous ideas do you know what
they're doing
yeah I mean they made game our own so
they probably like well we know it we
got it yeah yeah yeah where the [ __ ]
well they hit a home run for sure of
every cycle of shows they always have
fun that goes oh my god did you watch
The Outsider no it's great I watched
make millions
that was fantastic I didn't see that oh
that's the McDonald's one is that each
pillow as well it's HBO yeah good my
cousin made that it's greatly your
cousin cousin made it no [ __ ]
yeah it's fantastic it is such a cool
[ __ ] story the whole scope of that
scam is it will [ __ ] blow your mind
what is the scam so it was a lottery
thing
like that from so you obviously remember
the Monopoly game that you would play I
don't so weak though yeah oh you're kind
of healthy but back back [ __ ] so but it
was humongous so what happened was they
would do it like maybe like twice a year
where they would go the monopoly
McDonald's game and what happened is you
go to McDonald's and you would buy a
Happy Meal a Big Mac and on like the
fries and the drink would be like a
peel-off thing and you could win prizes
so you pull off a thing and you like you
could win it could be it's something as
small as like you want free fries so you
could be like yeah I got you know I won
another order of fries or a Coke or a
jetski or a car and then there were cash
prizes million dollar prizes so by by
playing the game which was essentially
buy something buy a meal and it would
drive up sales obviously right like
sales would go way up because people
were wanting to win these prizes
well everybody that won for this I want
to say I forget now but like 15 year
period or something they were all in on
a scam they were all fake winners a guy
was stealing pieces and giving them to
people connected to him it was all a lie
nobody was legitimately how did he do
that that's the whole that's the series
man it's shocking fascinating because at
one point there's this the this guy's
giving it to you know people he knows
and they're talking about it in the
series like people connected to him
they're like after a while it's like
it's weird that you know 10 winners have
have won in like this 300 mile radius
and eight of them are Italian we're like
we got to branch out a little bit
because no one's like tipped off yet
because the guy was you know Italian he
was going like friends and family yeah
it was it was really [ __ ] crazy
and then amazing they kept their mouth
shut they've kept their mouth shut and
they would have gotten away with it I
mean they were getting away with it
it was just it was they got tipped off
FBI got tipped off
and then this whole investigation that's
what the series it's a six-part series
that's what it reveals is just the scale
and the scope of this incredible scam it
was a scam and did this guy work for
McDonald's no there's all these
different characters in it but basically
McDonald's had to hire a company that
would oversee the game like the security
of the game and they would also have to
hire another company to print you know
like the game pieces and all that and
within those companies the corruption
light McDonald's didn't know and it it
but the story is fast and the characters
are outrageous to us I mean the Colombo
family is part of it you know the crime
family I gotta watch it it's good man
it's really good the there's so many of
those multi series or multi show
documentaries now that are fascinating
oh yeah like wild wild country like that
kind of [ __ ] were you just like why and
with it and when these networks get
behind something like that like this
Tiger King two things you're like man
you know that's why you need that
platform right like an HBO yeah it's
likes to be like tell us the whole story
right it's [ __ ] awesome yeah or wild
country country you need something
that's gonna play out for five or six
episodes for three episodes in you like
Wow how the [ __ ] did I not know yeah
what was that one you remember the one a
couple years ago was it the staircase
something like that about I never saw
that one that was [ __ ] good someone
killed his ex-wife yes yes dude and and
you just cannot believe some of the
twists and turns of something like this
it's just and then there was like that
part of that I mean I'm jumping around
and the Apple theory where they're like
maybe an owl came and attacked her and
that's what yes yes yes and they were
like there were hours in that area it
could have happened like people have all
these conspiracy theories it's amazing
how many people got away with crimes
before like DNA evidence do you really
think about how like how easy it
probably was for people yeah 25 years
ago
sociopath oh yeah yeah around whacking
people no cameras no DNA yeah I mean the
the what's the big one that we just the
Golden State killer well that was the
one that Patton Oswald's wife was
working yes she she was writing that
book
what are you playing over there yeah
what is a I was looking at the video
that Robert Durst guy he's on trial
right now that was the other one that
[ __ ] series was mastic what was the
show called I don't remember that's
where I got that song yeah dad blood
yeah yeah I remember that I was in a we
were doing a gig and I was like check
out this song mmm except that's where I
got that song the bad blood yeah the
jinx jinx did you watch it
don't [ __ ] excellent yeah I read the
story but I didn't watch it it's really
good and it's super creepy like you're
following along and then in the final
episode and he's doing his weird [ __ ]
he has black eyes you know like there's
no color they're black and he gets up to
use the restroom and the mic still hot
and he's talking to himself in the
restroom you see like the cameras like
locked off filming a wall he's like it's
a [ __ ] weird moment why does he have
such black eyes what's that about I I
don't know man this this trials going on
right now
might be on hold because of the Orion
yeah it just started earlier this month
like two weeks ago that's another really
cool series how crazy is the Harvey
Weinstein oh no no no that's gonna kill
him right I think so I mean we don't
know but he really looked like I mean he
always look like [ __ ] but he looked like
particularly a hot bag of [ __ ] like what
a trial oh my god and for the sentencing
when he came in with the Walker and
everything like what the [ __ ] do you
think that that was a scam that he was
trying to pretend that he was more hurt
than he was probably probably I mean he
it was a movie producer so he knows
right yeah I play it up yeah but he did
look like [ __ ] he really did in a way
that you can't fake like his face was
hanging on
you look fat and he he did look like he
was like I don't know like needing that
support yes of that you know I mean the
guy was walking upright a few months ago
it seemed like I know well also the
stress of that life of having the the
weight of his past come tumbling down on
him and imagine going up to Harvey
Weinstein four years ago and go dude I
want to show you what the future looks
like for you he'd be like I'll [ __ ] out
of here that's never gonna happen
never never man yeah me imaginator
imagine going up to Cosby and telling
him that no like you're the most beloved
father figure in this country yeah I
mean just before that like just before
things went sideways
he not he wouldn't have [ __ ] I'm like
what are you talking about yeah I almost
think that his story is less shocking
the result mmm like the Harvey Weinstein
thing I guess I didn't know he was a
piece of [ __ ]
I had never no idea but I knew that
Cosby was right we had all kind of heard
that Cosby is a piece of [ __ ] we all
know that know anything about Harvey
Weinstein I just knew he made movies I
know yeah I guess I mean with Cosby I
always knew he was a womanizer I didn't
know there was like you know date rape
any any no I had heard that you'd heard
that I didn't you know I heard that on
the set of news radio Wow and then 90s I
had heard that he was drugging women
well that's when he was probably pretty
active with it you know it was I think
that one was The Cosby Show on the air
in the 8th late 80s early 90s I think so
it was probably just getting done yeah I
was on Newsradio was 94 and I remember
like what he drugs people like so I
think candy Alexander's woman so they
were talking meet you I mean there's
probably people on set that had
experienced it maybe yeah yeah could be
but I hardly I didn't know anything
about I just the Harvey thing I just
thought he I mean just a big fat ugly
movie producer oh yeah and also I think
when that story first broke there was
some ID like it was kind of implied this
guy was a gross
you know like show me your tits kind of
I didn't write as the story details came
out you're like no this too is like a
full-blown like great like rapist that
you would read about in the newspaper
you know I mean like he actually pushed
women down I'll hold them down yeah he's
a real [ __ ] animal and then he was
like what what's the problem and he
fully shameless completely disassociates
with what he did I think he was living
this crazy life where he could get away
with anything like a king I mean we've
talked about this before that like that
behavior of Kings like gluttonous power
behavior where they just yell at
everyone and off with their head and
yeah bring her over here just like that
yeah that kind of [ __ ] well when you
also that his story revealed yet like
the scope of payroll mm-hmm he had like
photojournalists editors I think lawn
fawn like but mafia kind of [ __ ] does
you know like I pay you to [ __ ] watch
out for my bad deeds yes
so he really was doing well even more
disgusting it was in his contract like
if you have one sexual harassment claim
it'll cost you this much if you have to
you have to pay us this much like it was
written into his contract so they knew
they knew they knew me but how come
nobody else gets in trouble for that
yeah I don't know yeah I mean how do you
what do you what do they know that's the
question in a jail hospital he's at
Rikers son but in the in their medic
unit think so oh you think that's
top-tier qualities are up tier top of
the food chain they have a bunch of
Corona cases right now at Rikers it's
like a it's a big issue of course you
have no windows they're letting a bunch
of people out right now that I have like
probation violations or something oh let
him spread it could move that's the next
thought hilarious let him out yeah
unless you're letting him out into a
furnace
look I mean that [ __ ] if it did that to
that Olympic swimmer that 31 year old
guy wrecked him was gonna do to Harvey
Weinstein oh my god
no he's oh this is what I want to talk
to you about the [ __ ] comments of
people mad at you because you're doing
shows in Spanish are hilarious I get a
bunch of emails hilarious how mad people
get well the funny thing is like so for
people that don't know like I just I got
a deal
with Netflix where they were like do an
English special and then a Spanish
special and they actually offered me to
take like you can just translate that
special and shoot it I was like that's
kind of boring so I'll try to you know
work on some new stuff for the Latin
audience and translate like a few bits
and then in order to shoot it I just go
I just need a bunch of reps like you
would in English
I just need shows in Spanish so I
started doing that you know and started
doing are you fully fluent like you
could have conversations with people
there's no hitch just like you'd have a
conversation with me yeah I can have a
conversation with anybody in Spanish and
you've been like that your whole life
there's like times where the the level
of fluency goes higher like especially
from immersed like living right and
there's no mic who do you practice with
yeah I mean there's there's definitely I
have my hiccups in that like I might
grammatically say something incorrectly
mm-hmm
they'll definitely know what I'm saying
and then that's one of the things I work
on is that I record these I send them to
a Spanish tutor I go really
yeah I go did I say anything incorrect
in this is especially like what the [ __ ]
is wrong she goes I'm not going to she
goes I'm not going to comment on your
material she goes it's not what I'm used
to but I'll help you with the
grammatical thing so she you know she'll
be like you should have said manual
instead of admah okay so we work on
things like that you know like make sure
you say it correct because the main
thing is I don't want someone to be
distracted because they're like that
sounded right of course so broken
English I guess you know I don't know
fluency level is probably like 8 or 9 or
something Wow
but I mean you know it gets better the
more I I work on it and it gets worse
the longer I leave it so
that's why I started doing the podcast
in Spanish that's why I've been doing
these shows and all I did was I would
announce hey I'm gonna do a Spanish show
I did one an Oxnard I did one in Ontario
I had these Texas ones booked for April
where one night in each of this in
Houston Dallas Austin to San Antonio and
when I posted them they're like people
are like hey these shows are in Spanish
and I go that's what it says in the
[ __ ] on the marquee on the ticket on
the like this show is in Spanish and
they're like yeah I can't [ __ ]
understand it though
guys all speak Spanish I'm like I know
this is for somebody else and they're
like they're like but why don't you add
a show in English and I'm you know
you're trying to like go like well I
will do that show in English later like
when the English hour is ready because
I'm just releasing a special so I got to
build a new hour before I come to
Houston and show it you know and they're
like yeah but you should just do it you
should just do it while you're here and
I'm like yeah but that's not you know
and then I don't know I just
but people have been like you're a
[ __ ] idiot for Spanish why I put
screen grabs of yeah I left there there
handles out yeah I read a few of them ah
yes I got more I got more but you do oh
yeah yeah and people are like and then I
have the ones they're like I bought the
ticket and I didn't realize that this
was Spanish and I would like a refund
and I'm like don't talk to me about it
you go first of all on the site it's
it's called Tom Segura in espanol and
that's what it says in and then it's
like if you speak English this is not
the show for you and they're like I
didn't look at it I'm like what do you
want me to do man so you take it's on
Craigslist
yeah so yeah people yeah got fired up at
me for not adding the English imagine if
you were responsible for returning all
your tickets like you'd never be able to
do anything did you get messages like
that they're like hey I think I want to
exchange this ticket I don't know what
kind of messages are yeah yeah I don't
know I got I'm so much happier
I don't know yeah oh well I'll tell you
this my special came out today
I have not gone to look at I read some
good reviews yeah yeah of your [ __ ] yeah
okay I haven't even checked it out yeah
I read I read a couple good reviews and
some I think one of them was Washington
Post oh it's great
that's cool yeah I'm happy but ya don't
read any I don't get into it I do
remember I'm the last tour you know
especially on the bus you just said
there you read everything reading three
people are like I bought tickets Friday
show I'd rather come this Saturday show
and I would like at the Chicago theater
okay
like up dude yeah hit them up what am I
gonna do like you can figure this out
for me like okay like you have plenty of
time to be making these 20 minute phone
calls to reroute is this Steve to get
the Saturday tickets yeah no it is but
you you post and walk away right yes
yeah I don't read [ __ ] it's a way to do
it I've been doing that for a long time
now it's amazing yeah changes everything
if you have discipline but you have to
have a discipline and not read your
comments yeah you know because I know
people that read them and they go crazy
and they respond to them and argue with
them like that's the that's the problem
too is that you not only have to avoid
reading if you are reading you have to
not engage in the back and forth no you
can't you can't because a lot of people
are just trying to get your attention
and then a lot of people are also crazy
yeah if you're writing to me you're
talking to the void yeah I'm not I'm not
reading anything it's just better that
way man yeah it's better for you
mentally for sure for sure yeah yeah
it's just you only have so much time you
know and you get trapped reading stuff
about you and and and go what who said
that why are they saying that like you
know if you have [ __ ] up you know if
you said something stupid do just try do
your best
yeah you know especially like what we do
and especially if we're doing shows or
podcasts or anything like that where
you're you getting high and you're
talking crazy
oh yeah trying to be funny and sometimes
you swing and miss and sometimes you
sometimes you hit a home run and yeah
you never know
but if you
delve into the comments and start
reading all the things that people say
about you and tailoring your your act
towards your your your tailoring your
podcasts or your the way our way you're
talking based on the kind of people that
are willing to leave comments in the
first place right and you're also
catering it to the loudest voice I'm
just saying like oh you're loud
exactly okay that is the number one
problem with social media that's what
I've tried to explain to people that
like read social media and talk about
Twitter and Instagram you know like well
there's so many right-wing Trump
supporters that this there's so many
left-wing Bernie supporters to do that
and the Bernie bro and this and that and
no that's not true what's true is on the
fringes of the left and the right you
have losers that spend all their time
calling people out and talk and [ __ ]
online and I've studied these people I
study these people for years because
I've been fascinated by people that
engage in these Twitter beefs with
people and so I have a few of them
bookmarked and I go to check them and
some of them I would bookmark and I'm
like this guy has done nothing yeah but
talk [ __ ] online for the 12 hour crazy
and there's a lot of them like that yeah
there's a lot of in the most virtuous
the ones who are trying to get the most
reactions and they're calling out
celebrities for this calling out people
for that there's just so much of that
online it reminds me of something you
know some some things but someone says
just stick with you sometimes yes you
know like and you just I don't know that
you can't explain why but you go like
that just sticks with me I remember one
time talking to a guy who goes you know
there's a lot of unstable people out
there and I hear his voice all the time
like about this type of mouth yeah
there's a lot of unstable people a lot
of unstable people that also have access
to a phone yeah and then they just start
running off to the races don't crazy
yeah yeah there's a lot of it but
there's also you know it's a lot of
nonsense on both sides just the social
media just the the wanting people to
like you
like did you see that imagined song all
those knuckleheads got together and
saying imagine there's no heaven this
not the time when everyone's Grammys
dying you [ __ ] idiot to sing imagine
there's no heaven and there's this sense
of you feel like they've that they feel
like they did something yeah she's so
happy gal gadot whatever [ __ ] I did
Wonder Woman she's got this beautiful
smile on her face and so happy to sing
that thank you just like like she's
seducing you yeah I lost my job at the
meatpacking plant but gal gadot sang it
man it's a terrible version you guys
suck at singing yeah why are you even
singing publicly I didn't even post but
I I tried to do one where I first of all
I tried to do that where I go imagine I
just started laughing hysterically so
then I did one where I go I want to
connect with all you guys so let's just
jerk off together I'm not used to this
hand this hand just try to connect with
all my fans but it's such a dumb move to
I can't believe how many people I mean I
guess that she must have reached out to
them sent me of you singing up and they
want to be like tight where they're like
sure Wonder Woman yeah I'll do it yeah
okay okay
I couldn't keep I tried to stay off [ __ ]
stay offline you [ __ ] I try get off your
phone yeah I've tried to do it because I
wanted to I wanted all of us to to mock
it I think I have it I think the some
comics did something like that yeah yeah
wait like I saw Eric Andre and then like
slap on my slob on my knob that's what
they did right do they exactly yeah they
did like a parody of it was great well
it's the weird thing is you know people
are sitting around going all people
think I'm cool if I do this yeah yeah
yeah you know instead of like just
capturing a genuine moment in your life
which is really hard to do on social
media anyway because you feel like a
[ __ ] dork you know it's a weird
feeling for though is like let Majan you
had worked with Gao right I thought
about this too like you did something
you were in a movie or something
and then she hits you up I am trying to
do this you have that moment of pause
especially as a comic cuz it was like so
much self-awareness but you're like
that's gonna be lame as [ __ ] and then
you have to like figure out a tactile
you know coaster just just notice 100%
100% first of all I could give two [ __ ]
whether or not I'm ever in a movie again
ever two [ __ ] whether or not I talked
to her
first like what's up she's like will you
sing imagine a line from imagine and if
I'm in it friends with her yeah that's
what I'm saying I would have to say
listen you're awesome I think you're
great yeah that is that is a ridiculous
idea yeah it's so lacking in
self-awareness and so ridiculous I let
me tell you what I would do if I was
even if I wasn't a comic if I saw
someone do that
I'd be like what in the [ __ ] do you
think you're accomplishing with this I
felt so much better today seeing
celebrities singing imagine you made it
better
I was not really yeah I mean Grammy died
choking on her own vomit but I feel like
the world's better because gal gadot so
pretty gal gadot and she started it off
imagine there's no heaven and then at
the end big smile she did it like a
really like sincere look into the camera
like look what I did for you
did she I mean yeah I thought I didn't
get to it she's like hmm I feel
connected to you yeah there's some
people man that get real self-indulgent
and self-righteous with that [ __ ]
social media it's exposed a lot of
celebrities for being real dorks yeah
yeah of course you know they should be
exposed for that but they never got a
chance to be exposed before they would
you know it's night show they do these
things you do these interviews
everything was real fluff yeah you just
leave him alone with a phone or you get
great stuff you see Tom Hanks wife
singing along to Naughty by Nature I was
really surprised yeah it was good though
it was fun so me good exceptional yeah
yeah no makeup she's having fun hip hop
array
here's the thing that that cadence and
like that that rhyme pattern yes it's
not easy to mimic no it's not easy to
mimic no she did a good job but it's
also so obvious that she wasn't trying
to be anything other than have fun yeah
well when you're drinking children's
blood every night for dinner you have
fun you know I think sure it helps you
keep your rhythm going
mmm yeah no she was just having fun
that's revealed that she's super cool
yeah with no makeup right yeah she's not
trying to get dolled up no like there's
these people that some people are doing
these like quarantined like day five
here we are day five and it's like so
contrived and super contrived I guess
they want to connected people and they
want to talk to people but oh I mean
what are we doing
yeah I mean are we doing that what are
we doing yeah we are we are but we're
having a conversation we would have this
conversation if there was no microphone
yeah I probably talk a lot more [ __ ]
about people yeah I mean that's always a
big component of a good time it's fine
what's the talking shit's fun I keep
thinking about that meet we had [ __ ]
Vegas man oh so good yeah we're bizarre
meets yeah fantastic
that it used to be the SLS and now what
is it forget they change the name though
remember that yeah
sans or something switch back to what it
was yeah Sahara
I'm Sahara I think it's the Sahara
whatever it is the [ __ ] that bizarre
meets place god damn Azhar good yeah
yeah you gotta have maan I would love
talking dope yeah I've seen him on board
Dane Show
yeah yeah he's that that place was
phenomenal I love how they cook over
wood - you walk by and you see the the
hardwood coals and the grill grates and
they know what the [ __ ] they're doing
they told us it would take an hour to
cook the steak yeah yeah we're like an
hour yeah like yeah an hour and the
stakes are huge so just order one steak
I was like really
yeah 1/3 pound steak okay
anything dude we are the two though
amazing god animals good yeah what a fun
weekend just randomly we happen to be in
Vegas the same time so cool yeah that's
cool and something like that yeah yeah I
was bummed we're to leave before the the
last three fights dude you missed the
Whaley's young Johanna you and Jay check
fight which is one of the greatest
fights in the history of the sport
I saw you saying you keep thinking about
it dude all day I'd be speed four days
four days they'd be as close as a fight
could ever get a lot of people thought
you wanted one a lot of people thought
Whaley won but it was amazing
it was amazing [ __ ] war really came
down like you could have judged it
either way yeah yeah he could have yeah
yeah it wasn't I mean they gave it to
Whaley was a split decision but it was
you honest head it was so close her
forehead ridiculous and never never even
responded to it and it didn't react to
it just threw bombs and we know we
missed that knockout where you guys were
like where you mémé doubt you and DC
which one there was a knockout like
third to last fight big ass knockout mm
you know I'm talking about yeah
just after yes yes beneil dariush and
[Music]
yeah I think we mr. Carlos joke are
close it was a crazy battle and your car
hit him with a right yeah just saw but
kneeled are used in real trouble
and then Vanille Darius came back and
knocked him out yeah there it is yeah
Neil was really rocked and your car is
he only has one loss in his whole career
and it was a close loss and he came
[Laughter]
those bunkers right next to him and we
left for that [ __ ] was that the net that
must been the next fight yes I'm sorry
you missed it missed that yeah that's
the main event - well you had a show to
do yeah it's show your boy Josh Potter
yeah he's hilarious yes he's really
funny man it was my first time seeing
him
he's really funny good guy too I like
hanging out with them on Buffalo's
finest I love watching new comics new
comics new comedy yeah I love watching a
new comic that I've never seen her act
before yeah and you get to see them like
and he seems like a guy's been doing
about 10 years uh-huh
there's about 10 years yeah yeah that's
a fully-formed comedian you know it is
he's a fully-formed comedian great guy
great guy and he's a headlining now
starting to heaven that's great so he
deserves it he's really good I was
impressed
yeah I've been I've been taken on the
road for a few years now and he just
gets better and better and he yeah man
he is a couple bits that really floor me
he's really good you can't even give
away the premises no you can't no I do
love amounts a the ones I was like the
way he wants to die really no he's
really good it was cool to hang with
them too you know it's just hanging with
comics is the best dude it's about the
best the most fun I mean if you if we
hadn't seen you guys we would've just
hung out with each other all weekend
yeah and then you're like oh there's
more comics here
okay hang out with them yeah so it's
always and they get to eat
chill yeah but it was the beginning of
the coronavirus things were a little
weirded out bro I also think about so
what my manager was in town he had
friends in town so after one of the
shows I want to say was the second night
we also went to a cigar bar and you
start thinking about like uh all of us
all the contact and get in casinos two
casinos are just [ __ ] that's another
thing
dude Las Vegas is shut down so it's so
wild to think about how those you know
those casinos are just active people and
now how about all those people that
count on that
yeah dealers the people ever clean the
play waitresses yeah I've done
everything shut down for how long how
long they plan on shutting Vegas down
for they announced like last week they
said they would reopen casinos may 16th
then today earlier today Trump was like
there's no way this is going past Easter
so like he was about ripping and roaring
again but he's not basing anything that
he's saying though on science no or on
viruses no of course not
yeah yeah he should shut the [ __ ] up
he's going
hunched well he wants everything to
bounce back because he wants the economy
to bounce back course the governor of
Texas had to take on it too
he's like I would rather put myself in
danger and I'm in a high-risk group of
catching this disease and have the
economy come back okay
yeah I don't know man I don't know I
don't know when I you know it's like I
had a take on it before when I see a
Juris Elba I'm like he looks great
those NBA players they look great all
these people are Tom Hanks is recovering
yeah maybe it's just like the flu but
then you read that 31 year old Olympic
swimmer and you know and you go oh that
guy's 31 and he's a stud he's an
Olympian yes literally an Olympian a
gold medalist by the way he's a [ __ ]
stud right and he said it was the worst
virus he ever experienced in his life
and then Michael yo Michael yo getting
really sick I was and there was two
college basketball players who died they
died yeah yeah not college basketball
players now but they played College in
the 90s and they died and they both died
yeah it was a my my Apple newsfeed this
morning I think about this virus too is
that there's there's this uncertainty
about you know when things will change
when the curve will flatten when the
economy but we also don't understand the
virus yet right exactly that's the part
that's really alarming that's the weird
thing is like some people just
experience no symptoms and it just goes
through their system and they don't ever
get it and then the other thing was
someone was telling me I forget who it
was
IRA buted to dr. Peter a TA yesterday
but I think I'm wrong someone was saying
one of the odd things seems to might be
Sam Harris someone's saying one of the
odd things seems to be that the more
contact people have with the virus the
worse it gets
hmm so some like medical profession
yeah medical profession errs yeah yeah
it's very strange you see the NBA player
today said he lost his sense of smell
yeah that's another thing that's one of
the things that Peter attea said smell
and taste going away yeah it's very
weird people lose their sense of smell
very weird it's it's uh it's spooky yeah
because it's um it's like well it's also
there's
these crazy conspiracy theories that Wu
Han is like some place where they have
some weaponized virus lab and so that
they're worried that one of the things
that this that makes this so scary is
that it could have snuck out of this
[ __ ] lab hmm but apparently they've
traced it to a very specific type of
animal I thought that this thing always
transfers I think Moshe told me this
that that birds need a pig the pig is
the perfect conduit of transferring like
the Burt bird disease won't come from
like straight to a person it needs to go
to a pig and the pig can infect what
about avian flu I don't know
avian flu came from Birds this maybe
that's and I think bats gave it to
pangolins do you know what a [ __ ]
penguin is mm-hmm Whitney was telling me
this that a Pangolin is like the most
the most what is the word you would use
where someone is uh transferring animals
I'm [ __ ] slow today man my brain slow
today yeah that uh the most exploited
most exploited animal and the worth you
know what a penguin is uh uh some weird
[ __ ] Hangul in Pangolin I think it is
never heard of that yeah there it is
that [ __ ] thing look it up there this
screen look that that thing that's
called a penguin penguin yeah that is
the most exploited animal in the world
and they eat them in China and so this
[ __ ] thing is where shots China has
laws to stop Pangolin trafficking yeah I
think it's freaky minik yeah they're
they have laws that they're they're
imposing now to stop the sale of wild
animals
you can't sell wild animals in the
United States but you can sell well you
can sell wild fish but you can't sell
wild animals the United States I some of
the weird things about fish what about
those like exotic people in like that
documentary you know like why aren't
those wild animals I mean for food oh oh
oh okay okay I mean for food okay
you can't like even in this country it's
like most trafficked
yeah adorable Pangolin is the most
trafficked animal in the world how is
that possible ask Whitney Cummings she's
the one who told me it seems to be true
yeah it's in the New York Post as well
there it is the rainforest of the Congo
Cameroon and Central African Republic
lives an elusive mammal that looks like
a cross between an anteater and
armadillo and a pinecone and thanks to
poachers the Pangolin is the most
trafficked animal on earth in April of
2019 Singapore seized a world-record
twenty five point six tons of Pangolin
scales worth seventy six point five
million from an estimated thirty eight
thousand of the creatures in December
the scales from some fifty thousand
African penguins were seized by Chinese
authorities why what do they do for it I
don't know it's because of this scale
this unique feature that makes them a
target said Tessa almond a volunteer for
the Sangha Pangolin project a
Preservation Society the Pangolin buries
burro to create holes so the scales are
associated with circulation it's used as
an ingredient in traditional Asian
medicines they used to help mothers for
lactation and for blood pressure but
none of this has been clinically proven
so it's like Tiger teeth and yeah yeah
and tusks yeah there's so much of that
[ __ ] I was talking to a Chinese guy
about that yeah and I was saying well
what do they know that rhino horn
doesn't work and that they could get
viagra
I'll give it's make your dick hard
viagra definitely works oh it's not even
that he goes a lot of it is a status
thing it's like so if you are a really
wealthy Chinese businessman and you're
into this kind of stuff like you want to
show that you skirt the laws a right
animal track shark fin soup right like
isn't that wearily that tastes good but
I'm saying that's isn't that something
where there's like some type of probe
it's restricted and then they're like
yeah but I'm oh yeah I'm the man so yeah
this yeah I think I don't know what kind
of restrictions they have about that in
China but across the world
rhinos it's there but they want that tea
that they make at a rhino horn because
it just makes my eye come
discuss business over rhino tea oh yeah
I mean yeah I get why that happens but I
don't want any well China's so weird
right because it's a weird combination
of capitalism and communism yeah and not
just comment but a military the
communist dictatorship it's interesting
you know speaking of like the virus the
way the way China
lock down Wu Han yeah when they decided
to mmm it's a there's no [ __ ] around
yeah no [ __ ] around 11 million people
in that city went through the streets
spraying some distant they sent 40
thousand workers to Wu Han to be like
handle this
lock it down clean it up yeah just boom
in one city and they what's it like now
there it's there well here's the thing
you can never trust with the state
governor you know the state media says
but they were saying that all their new
cases are inbound
so it's travelers coming in how
convenient it's all these [ __ ]
Italians
yeah coming over here for shark's fin
soup and rhino tea [ __ ] pasta virus
[ __ ] yeah it's the rigatoni virus now
it is you guys did it well they're
saying that the America could be the
next epicenter yeah well New York is has
more than 5% of the world's cases right
now
does it really yeah it's growing to well
New York has 25,000 cases as of this
morning that's 5 percent the world's
cases that's what that's what the news
was last night they say that for every
one person that tests positive ten of
them have not even been tested that have
it yeah there's there's for sure way
more cases yeah because it's impossible
to get a test a test yeah yeah like try
to try getting a test right now in LA LA
had they started a website yesterday
with all the information how to get it
tests and they're like first of all meet
this criteria are you over 65 I mean
it's not really yeah part of it yeah
Jesus do you have these symptoms
you can't even order one online if you
can get a test going right now you could
be a great business it would be Jeff
Bezos and it would be a great way to
like you know figure out who needs to
really be staying home did you see the
story of the Senators that were in a
closed-door meeting in January about
coronavirus they just dumped all their
yeah yeah Burt Lafleur or whatever name
is yeah like that's not what happened
dude you had that is the definition of
insider trading that's what they
prosecute but what's happening to them
nothing nothing yeah what's up Jamie
stuffs happening I guess it just isn't
happening immediately yeah what is
happening ICC said that there might be
looking into it oh they might I'm trying
to get I might be looking into that
murder hmm I might be he's the chairman
of the Intelligence Committee yeah and
dumped all stock yep no they issued a
sharp warning Oh a sharp ones are
pointing stop don't do that again what
are you supposed to do if you know that
you're gonna lose all that money it's a
good question I think if you have that
type of Intel you uh you're not allowed
to profit well you're not allowed to use
that intelligence that's not open to the
public debate tell the it goes public
you know I mean like once that goes
public then you can act on it otherwise
you know the virus is already public the
virus is public but I think the the
scale yeah the magnitude of the impact
yeah estimate what's gonna happen when
it's closed or bang is like hey it's
about to go down and then you go call my
broker hey man it really is a movie yeah
it really is some kind of crazy virus is
really it is dude this is I mean like I
was said to you we don't have anybody we
can call and be like you remember when
this happened in your life no nobody
does nobody does yeah nobody does Bert
was saying that he thinks that in 2009
he had h1n1 made sense he said he said
he was so sick yeah he said he's never
been more sick in his life he said he
couldn't get comfortable somebody knew
had actually verified that evening yeah
yeah and that killed a lot of [ __ ]
people much more lethal yeah much more
isn't it interesting how they locked
that down I don't know it never spread
really I think it's because you got it
and if you're contagious you knew it
yeah this is a highly contagious yeah
and again the big problem is we don't
know how many people have it and then
you have these asymptomatic people how
many people died from h1n1 in 2009
50,000 is America
that's not that much no but I believe it
or not known about right but both the
thing about the flu every year can kill
as many as 90,000 people in America a
lot yeah
yeah and we never talked about it ever
know this says 2009 flu pandemic killed
18,000 people good P yeah I think the
the biggest that I remember reading was
ninety one thousand one year one year
ninety one thousand people died from the
flu I'm not sure if that's the United
States or North America the whole thing
is kind of crazy it's it's interesting
that Ron Paul was calling this a hoax
before he was saying you know just a
hundred people have died in America and
they're using this to take away your
civil liberties and then his son God son
did get it his son did get it afterwards
and then Nancy Pelosi's daughter tweeted
that Rand Paul's neighbor was right the
neighbor that attacked him like what
issue from that attack yeah he's got a
piece of his lung removed right the guy
told him broke five of his ribs and they
had to remove a piece of his lung and so
Nancy Pelosi's daughter says that the
neighbor was right like what is it what
does it mean the neighbors right because
the guy got sick the neighbors right to
attack him like two days ago his Twitter
account by his team tweeted out that he
was feeling fine was asymptomatic and
was not aware of any direct contact with
anyone that had it don't know how he got
it so he hasn't he's just how do they
test these people they're testing these
people you know when you hear about
these people getting tested and they
don't even have any symptoms like how
are they getting tested and why they
getting tested when some people are
really sick I've been questioned that -
I think there's a way up you can get a
private doctor that maybe you can get
access to a test like a private dock you
can pay extra money to get ahold of the
test really I think I don't know and I
don't know if that's the difference
between people just showing up at a
dr. Singh hey I think I'm sick can you
please find a test for me no like who
you want us to find one we don't have
access to that we have we're busy
versus like I don't know I'm just
guessing the weirdest thing about it to
me is the asymptomatic aspect of it that
some people don't experience anything
and other people get really [ __ ] sick
it's almost like if you wanted a disease
it spreads you have it let me have that
have one we're like 50% of the people
don't even feel anything and they just
spread it to 50 more people or a hundred
more people or thousands more people
it's weird man it just doesn't make
sense like a normal thing makes sense
you know because we haven't experienced
this one particular virus before we
don't really don't know anything about
how it's going to end where it's going
to go and then there's the possibility
that they could morph and that it could
you know be more contagious or more
deadly or more this or more that
apparently some people who have tested
positive for though are contributing and
they're they're extracting antibodies
from these people people that have
gotten over it but it's still going to
be the estimations there six months to a
year before they come up with a vaccine
I'm seeing rumblings of the false
positives online I don't double up too
much but I think that happens all the
time
okay false positives with all kinds of
diseases what do you got there fella
hand sanitizer of course yes everything
spray it spray it baby pharmacist told
me the other day that I don't know this
is [ __ ] the farmers have told me
that it's not effective unless you have
it actually dry on your hand like when
people go like that like you got to
actually have an alcohol drop
pharmacists told you this mm-hmm the
people I mean I don't know you know I
know if he's some [ __ ] lunatic but
that's what he said makes sense yeah
he's like it's not because people like
put it on then just he's like no no you
got to actually rub it all the way in
what is life gonna be like when this is
done that's just gonna be weird
what is life gonna be like we're gonna
be paranoid now I'm someone weird al'
yankovic tweeted everyone is Howie
Mandel now
I mean that's not theirs this is gonna I
do think it's going to spur this whole
generation of super germaphobes like oh
yeah especially like a kid I was
thinking about you know I said my kids
are too young to recognize what's going
on they don't know what's going on but
any kid that's you know their grandma
dies yeah or just is like I would say
between ages 6 and 13 that childlike you
know growing up age and you go like
schools I'm not going to school anymore
things are shut down we can't go to
restaurants don't go to the movies or
everything's different a lot of those
kids are gonna grow up super anxious
yeah and weirded out by this yeah scared
to travel yeah yeah like traveling I
think I personally never hesitate about
any term stuff I'm not built like that
but I have thought about getting back on
[ __ ] planes Oh
oh my god we circulated here nothing you
do about it
nothing you can do min no what are those
auntie VAX people gonna do what are they
gonna do well they only want to take a
vaccine what if they come up with a
vaccine for this [ __ ] and evac people
are the dumbest of all they're so
[ __ ] stupid
do you have Eddie's number you want me
to text him is he one of those too I
know he's like it's so stupid I mean
that's really idiots moronic yeah people
get mad at you I know they're suggesting
that there's something wrong with being
an anti-vaxxer stupid you dumb you don't
I mean just look at the the research
look at that the evidence is all there
it saves a lot of research is all
brought to you by the mainstream media
don't you understand how it works
sorry yeah why don't you go call Tom
Hanks yeah see you show up one of those
meetings I bet he believes in
vaccinations mm-hmm I bet he does now
what do they do what do what does an
anti vaccin
about coronavirus if they Pro if they
come out and they go we have the
vaccination now yeah I mean I don't know
pin him down
[ __ ] jab it in their neck it's a
totalitarian big fan well one of the
things that Putin is doing go to Roy
Jones jr. his Instagram page because Roy
Jones jr. is uh I don't know if you know
this romantic Putin fan and that no that
actually has a rush
for what yes he's a Russian citizen Roy
Jones jr. Roy Jones jr. monster gone
someone on swinging sweet sweet Russian
pool I bet it's the best I bet with a
honey pot you with is just so best I've
been it's like a fist Jesus Jones jr.
Instagram page no Instagram and his
Instagram page
Pensacola Florida one of the greatest
boxers of all time but not really
well-read in terms of totalitarian
governments and the consequences of make
you say that this these they're
threatening to lock people here goes you
have to choose between staying home for
15 days or prison for five years and
then Roy Jones writes simple crisp and
clear and that's how you fix stuff give
options a or be simple gotta love it I
don't know if you gotta love that
that's is that how they're handling it
there I don't know it might be [ __ ]
might just be a meme yeah but I think
he's just pro-putin yeah Putin hooks him
up yeah so I mean pictures of him
hanging out with Putin Putin comes to
his fights like some girls fighting over
there all over there too oh yes right
their buddies all that whole region
loves to go he loves them back yes I
think he's got a I think he's got a
Russian citizenship he does too yeah he
had an SEC violation recently free
insider trading he didn't disclose that
somebody that he was a big [ __ ] saying
yeah he was didn't disclose it
they were compensating him and I guess
that's an SEC violation so let me ask
you this while you're on this we're
we're all on this hiatus
how are you practicing your Spanish are
you just practicing it by doing your
podcasts yeah doing the podcast talking
to Pete the the best thing you can do I
mean I try to do it the podcast I try to
do it once every couple weeks but it's
by the best thing to do if you're ever
trying to like get better at any
language is immersion and it's forcing
yourself to have conversations you have
to talk you have to actually even if
doesn't even matter if you're new at it
or you're pretty fluent at it you have
to talk and so do you call your mom my
mom my cousin's the the tutor friends
Richard via is a comedian friend of mine
speaks fluent Spanish Francisco Ramos
this is a slow state today yeah yeah
Fabricio cabañal yeah Francisco Ramos
hey Suz yeah those guys all fluent
speakers yeah any conversation you can
have is gonna help you you know maintain
it or get better at it so when the when
you get back on the road is the number
one priority the Spanish special we get
give the Spanish special rollin or is it
just get your feet back on to you
I think it's get the yeah because I mean
I was at that last show I did March 11th
was 20 minutes of new English material
for like you know my stand-up right and
so I was like feeling pretty good about
that that I had like 20 new you know and
you and so I was gonna go into like a
bunch of work I feel like I would have
had 10 more by now right now yeah 10 a
month is doable it's doable if you're
working so yeah I mean I I've been
balancing both I did that 20 new while I
was working on the Spanish some stuff so
it's gonna be to go try to get back to
both men just doing the Spanish stuff
and getting my my regular English set
isn't gonna be weird to do set the first
time there's gotta be real weird strange
it's also it seems to me that we we have
this idea that things can't change so we
have to go back to the way they were
right that we have to it's gonna it's
going to be that way again we're we're
all
we're all comedy junkies right yeah yeah
I mean that's a I mean I've said this
many times before but it's true I feel
bad for people who've never killed they
don't know what that feels like
right I thought for a second like you
meant killed a person
no no I was like I feel bad for someone
who's never rocked a house yeah I don't
know what that's like to crush I think -
you know what the perspective changes
for them you ever have a friend watch
from the wings yes so they they then
they always it always feels different
they're like that's what you write feel
up there yeah
because they get to actually sense that
yeah you know now I'm remembering when I
came to see you I was so exhausted I
remember that I fell asleep in your
dress you're him on my band I'm not
doing so good and then I was thinking
about this coronavirus [ __ ] about I
better get back to the hotel
yeah and I crashed so hard I slept for
like ten hours that night which is
nothing normal for you right no it's so
weird yeah I was watching I was like
goddamn I got to sit down and I went to
your dressing room for a second I took a
leak sat down on the couch and I was not
I was hanging out with Jamie and I was
like I think I'm go back to the room
yeah like I'm hurting maybe I was
fighting something off maybe man maybe
but that's gonna be everybody from now
to there I think I might have had it for
a day or two
yeah but my immune systems amazing and I
shucks it off yeah this is it's so weird
that some people get it and some people
don't
there's nothing like this there's
nothing like this man well so I guess we
just keep doing this we just keep doing
podcast already popping them out as long
as we keep our social distancing and
wash our hands and stuff and I'm not
touching my face at all no I don't think
it's one of those things that you just
start doing even realize you're doing it
even on those announcements the doctor
lady lifts a finger
laid your finger and the other guys
scratched his face I mean they're all
touching their face but when she licked
her finger right after she said it's
like what are you doing maniac yeah of
course what you what what when was that
when she licked her finger it was about
10 days ago yeah it was only 10 days ago
what did that yeah that was about 10
days it's today the 20
or the fourth yeah yeah what's up three
weeks ago when she did that yeah Wow
whoa oh wait I'm just moving fast time
is moving fast yeah you can go the other
thing is strange is that you consume the
media you know like the news of it oh my
god is going on and then you can walk
down a street or drive down as for you
forget but you know I mean like there's
this sense of yeah what so I talked to
another cousin of Mines a doctor and
she's like oh I yeah I don't I don't
turn any of it on I just just get it out
of already know like what's happening so
I just choose not to have be bombarded
by it yeah you can be bombarded yeah you
know and it also shifts your your view
of the world so to heighten your anxiety
and your paranoia people were anxious
already people already have anxiety
issues they must be a [ __ ] wreck
right now absolutely because they
they're like oh my god I was right the
world is ending there's a mandatory
lockdown across the entire country
except Montana it's weird to have this
going on honestly and promote you know
like it's like there's so many people at
home so many people at home I mean I
look I understand the whole marketing of
and how that works but you're just like
you know you're on these calls and
they're like tell us making you special
isn't it crazy there's a pandemic so
what did you guys shoot it yeah what do
you mean by ball hogs and why do you
have all those pornhub girls they're
saying ball hog yeah
did you get those girls to say that are
they already saying ball they're already
saying it the you talk about my stories
yeah yeah they were already that that's
where I got the title uh-huh I was on
the road that was Jay and my D well and
I saw I saw a nice lady doing really
extensive stuff - this guy's balls right
and I was like I wonder there's a whole
sub-genre dedicated to this you know so
I typed it in and they're like you might
enjoy ball hogs
in that feature these ladies they
introduced themselves and they go and I
have a ball hog
so yeah they all do it and they really
work on guys balls like hardcore really
bad and so in the special I at one point
just reference I not that film but I
just tell people that that their mothers
are ball hogs and then and then I think
I think the you're really good this by
the way
picking titles I think it's one of the
hardest things you know you're like
you're doing your edit and you just want
your show together then we're gonna call
it [ __ ] no live from here it's just
the worst but yeah you've had good ones
but anyways I was going back and forth
with different titles and it was
suggested actually Josh my manager who
was like what oh and I smiled ear to ear
and I was like yes at that point what
was your tour named take it down oh yeah
you can't call it take it down you can't
call it take it down no I mean you could
but no no you can't the Hogs better yeah
yeah yeah so it's funny when you call it
tour one thing and then you call the
special I know and people were like you
should call take it down I'm like yeah
but they they don't want it to be called
take it down yeah
they don't Netflix isn't like dude it'd
be great if you call this take it down
bogs perfect yeah yeah and plus it has
that other meaning - yeah selfish
sharing yeah yeah a couple layers to it
yeah naming it and then but Dungey at
that feeling - when it's over that's
just like I just needed another couple
months
always always dude so we shot at the at
Austin City Limits great place beautiful
amazing venue the next day I had to move
venues because we would have shot the
next day as well the next day we had to
we stayed in Austin and we did two more
shows at the Paramount so if if we had
had the opportunity I just would have
stayed and done them because you guys
started doing I love it the for show
yeah would have done it I would have
done it you just didn't have the the
venue like we can't we can't do it so
you just did one night two shows when I
2 shows and the next night switched yeah
but but the next night you feel even
looser that's what I was saying yes I
forgot my train of thought
the next and
right you have the relief of like I shot
it and then like this joke taking it
here fine mm-hmm like I wish there was a
way you could make yourself do that yeah
well the way you can is by doing four
shows yeah that's that changed
everything for me when I started doing
four shows it may all shows be like a
show mm-hmm and like when I did Boston a
lot when I did strange times the first
shows where most this [ __ ] came from I
only had a couple of bits that I didn't
do earlier that I did that I had to
sandwich in there but most of the set
was from the first show because I was so
loose through the next night I added a
line to one of the kind of like table
setting jokes yeah and it just [ __ ]
crushed so hard that that I ITEC I took
it out as special I took the joke I go I
got it I gotta keep this joke I was like
I'm out so I can use it again well
that's good that you can do that yeah
that's good
I had it trimmed down to [ __ ] [ __ ]
haunt me makes you hate yourself you
should almost tape twice tape and then
tape again in four months I know it
would change everything right yeah tape
tape again in a month a month almost
enough time yes yeah film and then film
again and watch that in between there
like it'd just be such a gangster that
you're gonna pay double double taping
money [ __ ] especially today with all
this [ __ ] quarantine money oh my god
if Netflix paid you perv you cashing in
right now son
no and then what'll happen is I'll go to
negotiate next time it'll be like these
views will be like that wasn't real was
quarantine because you're a corona comic
yeah there's uh they're throttling
internet now yeah because so many people
are online that's that's what they're
really concerned about New York City
because like New York City hasn't even
hit its peak yet they think the peak is
within two to three weeks mm-hmm so the
cases you're experiencing now that's not
even peak so in two to three weeks
there's gonna be even more people at
home taxing the the structure of you
know all the services whether it's
electricity whether
it's internet everything all the
underlying things that you use you take
for granted because they don't never max
capacity at this right never well never
that's with fun with cell phones
whenever there's an emergency and you
can't make a phone call because
everyone's on their phone yeah and then
you realize like what are you selling
you're selling phones where everybody
can use the phone but you can't all use
the phone at once you're planning your
your whole the way your structure is set
up it's only set up for a certain amount
of people use it at the same time even
though you sold 300 million cell phones
yeah I can't really use them all at once
well it's busy right now in a structure
sucks yeah that's true that's true
they sell whack ass [ __ ] half-baked
infrastructure yeah yeah and you don't
realize it until something like this
happens like oh this there's not room
for all of us
yeah well the last apocalypse you and I
experienced we went to a nice hotel
that's right during the fire when we
stayed in the same hotel no let's leave
together
I'll leave together with you where you
want to go we got to go somewhere
Colorado get a Ranch Colorado be dope
what about someone really hot hot hot is
that bad I think so Arizona I have to I
was told I know there's like a theory in
it but like that the viruses thrive more
in the cold setting hmm I don't know if
it's factual hmm the virus just needs
hosts what about like Fiji yeah I mean
yeah but then they [ __ ] steal your
money what do you mean go to some weird
whack-ass foreign government you can't
keep your money over there that there's
no corona and Papua New Guinea right now
you don't think so because they're all
eating brains dude they're eating
cannibals they were telling that one of
the guys told me he had a when I was in
Australia like a month ago he's or two
months ago he goes I was working there
on some construction thing and he goes
you don't leave the area that they tell
you because you know things get crazy
and lawless if you venture out somebody
you know could [ __ ] you up no one will
ever know have you ever heard the semen
Warriors from Papua New Guinea mm-hmm
prepare yourself for this story there's
a tribe where when boys are young they
take them out of the tribe and they
teach them that in order for them to
fully grow they must ingest semen its
anally and through the mouth and so they
[ __ ] these boys make these boys suck
dick all all their life until they grow
full you know full size and then they
they turn around and do that young boys
somebody else yeah the semen warriors of
Papua New Guinea see like semen come
yeah and they have these names like anal
father and an anal son and yeah it's in
the way they refer to it it's like it
but it's a like some pedo like at one
point time started this sounds like in
order for you to grow you gotta suck my
[ __ ] and like well I want to be big and
strong I'm gonna grow yeah literally
there's a there's a whole tribe that
operates under that principle all right
and people have visited them I think
they're cannibals as well there's a lot
of cannibalism going on down there it's
a nice ribbon on the day you know that
what is it called
Crutchfield Jakob disease same thing as
mad cow definitely two punches it's a
prion disease the same prions are it's
it's a type of encephalitis I think it's
a type of in encephalopathy it's a freak
it's not like a virus and it's not
bacterial it's in its own category but
it is a it's a disease that affects
cannibals and the way they got its cows
is and I might be if you're a biologist
I'm so sorry I'm [ __ ] this up I know
I am cows got it from them serving cows
cow brains so mad cow disease the origin
of that was they would grind up these
cows and the parts they didn't use and
feed it to cows because it's protein
well you would give these cows as
cannibal disease that also exists in
Papua New Guinea in these cannibals
those cannibals get this disease and
these prions they they can survive what
thousands of degrees in temperature for
they've done experiments on people human
beings that had mad cow disease and the
instruments they used to operate on them
they ran them through these
sterilization cycles to three times and
the the prions are still alive what yeah
yeah they're literally almost impossible
to kill and there's a version of it that
it's making its way through deer
populations right now it's called
chronic wasting disease chronic wasting
disease is also a prion disease and it
has not made the jump yet does that mean
here to peep that's from deer eating
deer or no they don't know what caused
that prion disease but it is a prion
disease they don't think it's
necessarily from deer eating deer what
was the tribe that was in the news like
I want to say in the last 12 16 months
where they have no contact
you know what the I said North Sentinel
island yes yes that's I have a whole bit
about that you seem a bit no and this is
like the guy who was like I'm here yeah
save you put them up and then the Indian
is it the Indian government's like we
don't [ __ ] with yes the Indian Ocean
yeah yeah yeah there's a few places like
that real uncontacted tribes and another
one is there's a couple of them still
left in the Amazon and the problem the
ones the Amazon is these people have
land and they try to protect these
people because you know the land is
valuable yeah and so then they you know
people from these either mining
companies or oil companies they'll go in
and kill these people
[ __ ] yeah cuz I like [ __ ] you we're
taking your land this is a real issue
with that in the Amazon without going to
sassanid what's the Sentinel try it
what's it called the North Sentinel
island North Sentinel yeah middle the
Indian Ocean direct descendants of
people left Africa 60,000 years ago holy
[ __ ] yeah yeah that's one of the most
uncontacted places but they've all been
contacted everyone's been slightly
contacted at least historically but that
one is a particularly weird one I don't
think they're cannibals but they might
be but the the ones in New Guinea are
yeah you google seamen warriors of Papua
New Guinea that's gonna be what I read
about tonight yeah
all right ball hog it's on Netflix right
now go get it it's [ __ ] awesome
I didn't see the special but I
definitely saw you murder
with that material thanks man was great
to see you thanks for having me man my
pleasure my brother always let's get
through this together
you have to move together let's figure
out spots we got a spot down dude all
right I like to get the [ __ ] out of here
I'll do it if we have a spot and we just
find a cool spot we can get a bunch of
cool people to move up there with us and
then you know maybe burr could fly us
you know copter all right welcome flies
planes yeah somebody little uh little
Duval Lil Duval he flies planes he does
he's got two planes little Duval flies
planes that guys this [ __ ] I love that
guy his Instagram lil Duval's D bramble
area he's got one of the best Instagram
accounts on the planet Earth and he
updates it all day long it's like all he
does is just talk [ __ ] on Instagram he's
hilarious
all right Baha go watch it you [ __ ]
why even listening this anymore you
should be watching ball hard thank you
bye everybody bye thanks man
[Music]